WELCOME. TO THE STATE COMMITTEE
ON VETERANS AFFAIRS.
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE AND I ALWAYS BEGAN BIKE
KNOWLEDGE IN OUR FLAGS BEHIND US
HONORING THE ARMY NAVY AIRFORCE
RECORD COAST GUARD JOKE AND I
HAVE OUR VETERAN STAND UP. TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT'S HOW WE START
THIS MEETING.
THANK YOU LADIES.
AND GENTLEMEN THANK YOU.
OKAY WE'RE PROBABLY THE ONLY
COMMITTEE THAT DOES THAT BUT
THAT'S HOW WE ROLL IN THE
VETERANS COMMUNITY.
SO LET'S GO AHEAD BEGIN BY A
BIGGER ROLE.
ARCHULETA YOUR GROWTH.
RICARDO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
WILL PRESENT THANK YOU WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM LATE IN
GENERAL WE ARE GOING TO CONDUCT
BUSINESS AND TAKE VOTE.
AND VERY FIRST ITEM WE'RE GOING
TO GO ON IN A LITTLE MIXED ORDER.
SHIRLEY WEBER -- A. B. -- FOR
NIETY EIGHT AND LET YOU GO
AHEAD PRESENT THAT OUT OF ORDER
BUT YOU ARE IN A HURRY SO WE'LL
TAKE YOU FIRST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I AM A ON
A CONFERENCE CALL IN ABOUT TEN
MINUTES.
EDUCATION COMMISSION OF THE
STATES AND SELL REPRESENTING US.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANKS TO THE COLLEGE WHO
ALLOWED ME TO GO BEFORE THE MY
APPRECIATE THAT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB FOUR
NINE EIGHT WHICH WOULD EXAMPLE
VETERANS WHO OWN SERVICE
BUSINESSES.
I'M CITY AND STATE BUSINESS
LICENSE FEES.
THIS WAIVER ALREADY EXISTS FOR
VETERANS WHO MAKE AND SELL
TANGIBLE GOODS HOWEVER VETERANS
WHO SELL SERVICES CANNOT RECEIVE
THE WAIVER. FOR EXAMPLE OF
VETERAN WHO SELLS PAINT WOULD BE
EXEMPT.
BUT A VETERAN WHO PROVIDES
PAINTING SERVICES WOULD NOT BE
EXAM.
AB FOUR NINE EIGHT WOULD
MODERNIZE THE LAW TO REFLECT
TODAY'S SERVICE ORIENTED ECONOMY.
THIS BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY TO
VETERAN BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE
A SOLE PROPRIETORS OF THEIR
BUSINESS AND WOULD NOT APPLY TO
STAY PROFESSIONAL LICENSES SUCH
AS COSMETOLOGY OR CONTRACT OUT
CONTRACTORS LICENSES.
AB FOUR NINE EIGHT WOULD
INCREASE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR VETERANS WHO
SELLS SMALL SERVICE BUSINESSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WITNESS.
OKAY OF ANYONE HERE.
TOO THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
STATE YOUR NAME UNITS
[inaudible]
GONNA SESSION.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING.
AMERICAN GI FORM AND VETS.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL AND THE VIETNAM
VETERANS OF AMERICA ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD.
ANYONE ELSE HERE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
I HAVE MOTION.
WHAT I'M SORRY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
OKAY. TO A CLOSE THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY EIGHT DO YOU
PASS ARCHULETA HI OUR LITTLE I
GREW.
NIELSEN AYE.
AYE ROTH.
I AMBER.
I WILL.
THE BEST ENOUGH FOR YOU.
VERY FAST THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH WITH BASS IS WE'RE GONNA
HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR THE OTHER.
TWO MISSING.
RELATIONS THANK YOU.
OKAY -- WILL GO BACK TO THE
ORDER.
DRUG THAT WAY EVERYONE TO GO
GRAB SOMEONE ELSE -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER A QUIRK SILVA.
AND YOU HAVE A BE.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY GO
AHEAD AND PRESENT YOUR BILL.
I DO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
ALSO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
AS I KNOW WE ALSO HAVE OTHER
MILITARY MEN HERE -- AND WOMEN.
THAT HAVE SERVED SO WANT TO
THANK YOU -- I WANT TO BEGIN
WITH GOING BACK BACK INTO
HISTORY.
WHICH IS.
JUNE SIXTH NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
AS MANY OF US KNOW ANA.
THIS IS BEEN CALLED D. DAY ON
THE DAY THAT OUR YOUNG.
MILITARY MEMBERS AND OUR ALLIES
STORMED THE BEACHES OF NORMANDY.
AND WAS HAS BEEN CALLED THE
TURNING POINT IN WORLD WAR
[inaudible]
TWO THOSE MEN -- STORM THAT
BEACH MANY OF THEM WERE LOST AND
YET SOME OF THEM HAVE RETURNED
AND THAT GENERATION THE GREAT
GENERATION.
AT THOSE MEN ARE NOW AND LATE
EIGHTIES TO NINETIES AT NINETY
YEARS OLD NINE MID NINETIES WE
KNOW THAT ALMOST EVERY DAY WE
LOSE ANOTHER.
A GREAT VETERAN OF THAT TIME AND
NOT JUST THE WORLD WAR TWO BUT
ALL OF THE VETERANS THAT HAVE
SERVED US.
IN MANY.
AREAS THROUGHOUT THE WORLD
VIETNAM KOREA.
AND SO FORTH.
WITH THAT A COALITION OF
VETERANS CAME TOGETHER WELL OVER
A DECADE AGO AN ORANGE COUNTY I
TO START TO DREAM TO PURSUE THE
IDEA.
OF AN ORANGE COUNTY OR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY OF
THE CEMETERY.
THERE WAS NOT A SPECIFIED PLACE
IN WHEN I WAS ELECTED IN TWENTY
TWELVE I I HAD JUST.
READ AN ARTICLE MATTER FACT FROM
THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER.
AND WAS VERY COMPELLED BY THEIR
STORY TO BRING ASOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY TO
ORANGE COUNTY AND WITH THAT AS I
WAS THE VETERANS CHAIR AT THAT
TIME.
AND MET WITH THE CONSULTANT IN
IN LOOKED INTO THAT THEY SAID
WELL YOU NEED.
TO MEET FIND OUT INFORMATION AND
AND PURSUE I AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE DID.
AND WE MET I MET WITH THE LOCAL
VETERANS WITH THE COALITION AT
THAT TIME AND LEARNED ABOUT
THEIR OZELL. TO LOOK AT THE
GREAT PARK. FOR A SPECIFIC SITE
WHICH IS CALLED THE ARTIST SITE
AND THAT ARTIST SITE MEANT QUITE
A BIT TO THEM AS FAR AS NOT ONLY
THAT LOCATION BUT THE HISTORICAL.
SIGNIFICANCE I ACTUALLY WENT OUT
TO VISIT THAT SITE -- TO WITH
THE MILITARY MAN A BILL COOK --
SAT RIGHT NEXT TO ME TO PRESENT
THE BILL AND HE'S HERE AND HE'LL
BE PRESENTING ALONG AT TODAY.
BUT THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT.
THAT MEANT A LOT TO ME AND I
KNOW MEANT A LOT TO THEM WAS TO
MOVE FORWARD.
THAT -- PIECE OF LEGISLATION WAY
BACK IN I BELIEVE TWENTY
THIRTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE ART SO TO
GIVE YOU THE HISTORY OF WHAT
HAPPENED THEN ON MARCH ELEVENTH.
TWENTY FOURTEEN IRVINE CITY
COUNCIL BY UNANIMOUS VOTE THE
EXIT NEEDED THE ARTIST SITE.
AT THE GREAT PART AS THE BEST
POSSIBLE SITE FOR A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS MEMORIAL
PARK IN CEMETERY.
AT THAT TIME CRISTINA SHEA.
WHO WAS A COUNCIL MEMBER AND NOW
IS THE MAYOR?
DON WAGNER WHO WAS A SUPERVISOR
BUT IS NOW A WHO WAS A SORRY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND IS NOW A FOR
A SUPERVISOR FOR ORANGE COUNTY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEVEN CHOI WHO
WAS A COUNCIL MEMBER AND NOW ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND FORMER MAYOR LARRY A GRAN AS
WELL AS FORMER COUNCIL MEMBER AT
BASCOM VOTED FIVE ZERO TO NAME
THE ARTIST SITE AS A PLACE.
FOR VETERANS CEMETERY AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
LATER THE COUNCIL EVEN WENT SO
FAR AS TO OFFER A THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR.
FUND TO MATCH WITH THE STATE WAS
ROPOSING AND THAT WAS PROPOSED
BY THEN MAYOR JEFF LOWELL AWAY
WHO IS NOT ON COUNCIL.
ANYMORE HISTORY DEMONSTRATES
THAT THE STATE LEGIS LEGISLATURE
SUPPORTS A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
VETERANS MEMORIAL PARK IN
CEMETERY.
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION SELECTED
THE ARTISTS SITE AND ALLOW YOU
AT ALLOCATED FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE CALVET
CEMETERY AND MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS THE DOCUMENT THAT WAS
PRESENTED.
ALL OF THE SITE IN MAPS AND
ANALYSIS SO THIS IS THE TYPE OF
ANALYSIS THAT THINK CAL THAT
DOES -- THEY ARE EXTREMELY
SERIOUS AND VERY METHODICAL ON
THEIR NALYZING A PROPERTY TO BE
A STATE RUN VETERANS CEMETERY.
LATER ON WITHIN A FEW YEARS
AFTER THAT ON AN ALTERNATE SITE
WAS DETERMINED A SITE THAT WE
SHOULD LOOK INTO AND THAT WAS
ACTUALLY. FOR A LACK OF A FORMAL
NAME CALLED THE STRAWBERRY FIELD
AND THIS WAS OFFERED AS PART OF
THE LAND SWAP AND MANY OF US IN
THIS ROOM ACTUALLY VOTED TO FUND
THAT SO AS A WILLING LET THIS ON
MY PART AS THE AUTHOR.
WHEN THERE WAS ANOTHER SITE THAT
WAS BROUGHT FORWARD WE ALSO MOVE
TOWARDS THAT SITE WARNING TO DO
WHAT WE FELT THAT THE PEOPLE OF
IRVINE WANTED -- AND THAT WAS UP
WE MOVE TOWARDS LOOKING AT THAT
SITE TO SITE WE ALSO PUT UP AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT IS STILL IN THE CALVET SITE.
HELL THAT ACCOUNT.
IT BUT ALSO SUBTRACTING THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
FIRST ANALYSIS SO YOU CAN SEE
THIS KING START TO GET TRICKY IF
YOU'RE NOT.
REALLY CAREFUL ABOUT WATCHING.
HOW THIS MOVE FORWARD A LOCAL
REFERENDUM WHICH ARGUED AGAINST
THE STRAWBERRY SITE?
AND WAS ARGUING TO LOOK BACK AT
THE ORIGINALSITE WAS SUCCESSFUL
THIS ACTION STOPPED THE LAND
SWAP.
THE LAND SWAP TO THE STRAWBERRY
SITE.
AND PLACED IT BACK AT THE
ORIGINAL SITE.
MANY VOTERS BELIEVED THAT'S WHAT
THE REFERENDUM DID THE
REFERENDUM ACTUALLY DID NOT
PLACE IT BACK ACT THE ARTIST
SITE THAT'S WHAT OUR LEGISLATION
INTENDS TO DO -- SO THERE HAS
BEEN LOTS OF NEWS ARTICLES MANY
PIECES OF OPINION A LOT OF BACK
AND FORTH THING BUT WHAT I WOULD
SAY TO EVERYBODY HERE.
IS.
WE WANT A CEMETERY.
I THINK THERE'S A 100% AGREEMENT
THAT NOT ONLY DOES THE VETERANS
COMMUNITY WANNA CEMETERY.
PEOPLE IN IRVINE WANNA CEMETERY
THE ARGUMENT HAS BEEN WHERE SO
THERE HAS BEEN THE FIRST SITE
ARTIST SITE.
THE SECOND SIDE THE STRAWBERRY
SITE AND NOW A THIRD SITE THE
GOAL SITE.
NOW JUST TO LET YOU KNOW THE
GOAL SITE IS ACTUALLY NOT A GULF
SITE SO IN MY MIND WHEN YOU SAY
GOLF YOU'RE GONNA THINK OF
ROLLING GREEN HILLS AND A
WATERED AREA AND IT'S NICE AND
READY JUST.
TO THIS IS ACTUALLY NOT A GOLF
SITE IT'S MUCH LIKE THE ARTIST
SITE AS FAR AS CONCRETE AND SO
FORTH IT WAS NEVER MADE INTO.
A GOLF SITE BUT THAT BEING SAID
THERE HAS BEEN A 100% CONSISTENT
VOICES IN THAT.
UP THERE WE WANT DAIS CEMETERY
THE DEVELOPER THE CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS MAYORS HAST IN PREVENT
PRESENT HAVE ALL AGREED THAT THE
BIG CONFLICT IS WHERE.
SO ALL OF PROCLAIM THEIR SUPPORT
FOR A VETERANS CEMETERY YEP
PARTIES HAVE YET TO FORMALLY OR
OFFICIALLY IDENTIFY ONE SITE
THAT DEVELOPS THE NECESSARY
CONSENSUS.
SOMETIMES IT'S BECAUSE BECOMES
NECESSARY TO PRESS FORWARD MOVE
FORWARD TO GET TO THE POINT WE
WANT TO GET.
TO THAT. EIGHTEEN WITH NEW
MEMBERS HERE -- NEW MEMBER
SENATOR TOM UMBERG -- ALSO
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM DALY
WHO ALL HAS WORKED ON THIS
CONSISTENTLY SINCE.
TWENTY TWELVE AND OTHER
REPUBLICANS ASSIGNING.
SUPPORTERS REPUBLICAN MEANING A
SIMILAR YOU MEMBER PHILLIP CHEN
SENATOR LING LING CHAN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL BRO ALL HAVE
SIGNED ON TO THIS LETTER OF
SUPPORT FOR THE ARTIST SITE.
SO WHAT WE WANT TO DO TODAY IS
MAKE THE CASE TO YOU THAT OUR
LANGUAGE FROM THE ORIGINAL SITE
THE CHANGE TO THE ARTIST SITE.
BUT AND TERE'S MORE BUT WE WILL
ALSO WANT TO COMMIT.
HONESTLY AND WHAT DOES MUCH TAKE
YOUR INTEGRITY AS WE CAN SAY
THAT ALTHOUGH.
WE'D LIKE TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
WITH NO AMENDMENTS WE WILL BE
HAPPY TO IMMEDIATELY START IN
CONVERSATIONS.
THAT CAN BRING THE CONSENSUS TO
A 100% SO THAT WE DON'T FEEL
LIKE THERE'S A WINNER OR LOSER
IN THIS CONVERSATION.
SO WITH THAT I HAVE WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS.
PATRICK.
FUSS GO.
OF WHO IS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OFFICER OF FUSS GO
ENGINEERING OF IRVINE AND A LONG
TIME PROPONENT OF THAT OF THE
VETERANS CEMETERY IN IRVINE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN.
AND THANK YOU CHAIRMAN ARCHULETA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY I'M FLATTERED AND
I'D LIKE TO JUST ADD TO MY
INTRODUCTION I'M THE CEO FOUNDER
OF A TWO HUNDRED PERSON.
ENGINEERING FIRM WE MAKE THINGS
WORK.
WE HAVE TOP TIER CLIENTS THE
IRVINE COMPANY COSCO.
MY THIRD LARGEST CLIENT IS ROSE
HILLS THE LARGEST CEMETERY
OPERATOR IN THE STATE SO I KNOW
SOMETHING ABOUT LAND DEVELOPMENT
AND CEMETERY.
SO HOPEFULLY YOU'LL FIND MY
REMARKS CREDIBLE.
SO -- I PASSED OUT FOR YOU THERE --
BASICALLY A SUMMARY OF MY
FINDINGS I WAS RETAINED.
BY ONE GROUP TO ASSESS ALL THREE
SITES.
IT JUST AS AN ENGINEER.
TOTALLY -- AGNOSTIC POLICE IN
NEW TRULY TO ASSESS THE THREE
SITES AND GIVEN THE MERITS AND
ISSUES OF EACH.
SO I DID SO I LIKE TO SAY I'M
LIKE JOE FRIDAY FROM DRAGNET.
IT'S JUST THE FACTS MA'AM.
SO THAT'S ALL I'M HERE TO GIVE
YOU NOW IN THIS LETTER THAT I'M.
PASSED OUT TO YOU IS A LOT OF
THE STUFF I FOUND AND I'M SORT
OF CHEATING GIVING YOU THAT IT'S
A LETTER TO A CLIENT I HAD TO
REDACT THEIR NAME OUT.
SO FORGIVE ME FOR THAT.
ALSO IT ADDRESSES A FORCED SITE
WHICH IS IRRELEVANT TO YOU GUYS
IT'S AN ANAHEIM SO JUST IGNORE
THAT PART OF IT.
AND FINALLY THERE IS A LITTLE
UPDATE ON PAGE TWO AT THE BOTTOM
ON THE GOLF SITE AS IT'S
REFERRED TO THE RUNWAYS HAVE
BEEN REMOVED.
AND IT SAYS ON THERE THEY'RE
STILL THERE SO THAT'S OTHER THAN
THAT IT'S ALREADY PRETTY
RELEVANT AND I THINK YOU'LL FIND
IT USEFUL SO HERE'S MY FINDING.
WHY I'M HERE?
THE ARTIST SITE.
HAS THE STATE APPROVAL AND HAS
THIS FULL DESIGN REPORT WHICH
YOU SAW A MINUTE AGO WHICH IS.
ABOUT A YEAR OR TWO IN THE
MAKING SO YOU'RE ALREADY ON
SECOND BASE WITH NO OUTS ON THE
SITE.
IT'S READY TO GO IN MY
PROFESSIONAL OPINION CAN BE.
DEMOLISHED CLEARED BUILT AND
DELIVERED IN TWO YEARS.
TAKE IT TO THE BANK TWO YEARS.
ALSO THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING CERTAINLY TO ME HOPEFULLY
DO YOU ITS ASPIRATIONAL BUT THIS
IS THE ACTUAL ORIGINAL FLIGHT
LINE. NINETEEN FORTY THREE IT
WAS BUILT AT THE AIR BASE IT'S
STILL THERE.
THE HANGERS ARE THERE ON THE
CONTROL TOWER WE LOVE TO SAVE
THAT.
AND MAKE IT A PART OF THIS
VETERANS CEMETERY ON MEMORIAL
PARK.
THIS THAT MAKES THIS SITE UNIQUE
THERE ARE NO OTHER SITES THAT
HAVE THAT.
IN IN IN A CAN'T BE REPLICATED.
SO WHY NOT TRY TO SAVE IT AND
MAKE IT OF A LEGACY OF THE MEN
WOMEN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND OF
THEM THE WENT THROUGH THERE MANY
OF THEM WHO LOST THEIR LIVES IN
THE WAR.
THERE'S BEEN SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT CONTAMINATION I WAS
INTRODUCED.
HAVING WORKED ON THIS PROPERTY
FOR TEN YEARS I KNOW WE'RE ALL
THE SITES OF THE CONTAMINATION
ARE.
I KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT THEM WE
HAVE MAPS OF THEM.
WE'RE NOT AFRAID OF THEM THEY'RE
NOT THAT BIG A DEAL FRANKLY.
BUT WE CAN SET ASIDE SOME MODEST
CONTINGENCY BUDGETS FOR ANY
CONTAMINATION SAY THEY CAN BE
ACCOMMODATED IN PLACE THEY CAN
BE ENCAPSULATED OR YOU CAN JUST
SIMPLY REMOVE THEM [inaudible]
FINALLY.
THIS SITE IS HAS A GREAT SHAPE
TO IT IT CAN BE FULLY UTILIZE
FOR SIXTY THOUSAND GREAT SITES.
IT'S GOT INFRASTRUCTURE AND ITS
FRONT DOOR.
AND THERE'S NO HABITAT ON THE
SITE AND THE SEEK WERE APPROVALS
ARE IN PLACE.
SO TO ME THIS IS JUST A NO
BRAINER FOR PLAY.
BUT LET'S GO ON TO THE OTHER
SIDE -- THE THE IRREGULAR SHAPE
OF WHAT'S CALLED THE GOLF COURSE
SITE SHOULD JUST IMMEDIATELY
STIFFENED YOU UP JUST LOOK AT
THE PICTURE OF THE SHAPE OF IT.
IMAGINE TRYING TO DEVELOP
ANYTHING ON IT.
IT'S IT'S A PROBLEM IT'S GOT
LONG NARROW LEGS.
IT'S GOT A FIFTEEN HUNDRED FOOT.
PERFECT CIRCLE RADIUS SENATE
THAT MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE.
TO MANAGE EVERYTHING WOULD HAVE
TO BE DONE CONCENTRICALLY WITH
THIS CURVE SO RIGHT AWAY THAT
THAT IS A BIG MINUS FOR THAT
SITE.
SECONDLY THE FAA ANTENNA STILL
THEIR OPERATING HAS A FIFTEEN
HUNDRED FOOT RADIUS AROUND IT OF
A DEAD ZONE IT'LL ALWAYS BE A
DAD'S ON IT'LL BE WEEDS FOR EVER.
THAT'S WHAT YOU LOOK AT FROM
THAT SITE.
THIRD THE ACCESS TO THAT SITE IS
A LITTLE BIT LESS ATTRACTIVE
THAN TO THE ARTIST SITE BECAUSE
IT'S SHARED.
IT'S CALL BOSQUE DRIVE AND KATE
INSTRUMENT SHARED BY THE
RESIDENCES ARE ALREADY LIVING
THERE.
SO -- OOPS.
HAVE PEOPLE COMING AND GOING TO
THE MEMORIAL PARK IN THE
CEMETERY.
SOME TURN LEFT INTO THEIR
DRIVEWAY SOME TURN RIGHT INTO
THE CEMETERY NOT SO GOOD.
WHEREAS THE ARTIST SITE HAS IT --
SON WAY WHICH IS A COLLECTOR
THERE'S NO HOUSES ON GO STRAIGHT
IN.
AND FINALLY -- IF YOU GO TO THE
GOLF SITE FOR WHATEVER REASON I
CAN'T IMAGINE.
YOU'RE STARTING OVER SO YOU HAVE
TWO YEARS TO CATCH UP TO THE
ARTIST SITE.
AND BY THE WAY SOMEONE ASKED ME
SEVERAL TIMES ABOUT COSTS.
ON THE CEMETERY SO I CAN TELL
YOU THAT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS MORE THAN ENOUGH TO DO THE
CEMETERY.
SITE.
AND I'LL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU [inaudible]
THANK -- I I I KNOW [inaudible]
BRING UP.
THE BILL PLEASE.
THE STATE YOUR NAME LYFT.
LOG CLEAR AND ALSO YOUR COMPANY
YOUR UNIT.
I AM HARVEY LISTS A LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CIVIL ENGINEER A
RESIDENT OF IRVINE. FOR FORTY
THREE YEARS.
AND I AND MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
OTHER IRVINE RESIDENTS SENT
EMAILS TO ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THERE.
VOCIFEROUS SUPPORT.
FOR GOING BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
SITE EARLY.
SURE IN AT THE CEMETERY IS BUILT
ON THE ORIGINAL SITE.
THE ART ASIDE AND THEY GIVE
THEIR HEARTFELT REASONS WHY
THERE'S A HUGE AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION ACTUALLY IN THOSE
EMAILS THEY WERE ALL.
WRITTEN BY THESE FOLKS WHO ARE
EXTREMELY PASSIONATE ABOUT IT.
AND SO WE ADVOCATE PASSING ME
THESE THREE SIXTY EIGHT WITHOUT
ANY AMENDMENT AT ALL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RIGHT
THERE IN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE VETERANS
ALLIANCE OF ORANGE COUNTY.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL -- WE ALSO --
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR -- ON THE BILL.
AND TO TRY AND GET THE CEMETERY
BUILT I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG
TIME THE CLIENT THAT WE
REPRESENT ON THIS -- THINKS IT'S
LONG OVERDUE AND WE HOPE TO GET
THIS DONE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU GIVE ME SAID YOU YOU'D
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
THAT MEANS WITH.
ANY ADJUSTMENTS THAT MANY
ADJUSTMENTS AT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THE AUTHOR OF THE
PROPONENTS OR WHOEVER -- DECIDE --
TO YOU KNOW IF IF IF THERE.
DECIDED TO BE MADE TO THE WE
WOULD CERTAINLY.
WORKING WITH THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
TAKE YOUR NAME AND THE UNIT
YOU'RE WITH FOR COMPANY IF YOU
WISH [inaudible]
GOOD.
LIGHT THAT OVER.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CHASING AND SOLVE
THIS REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
IRVINE.
JUST AT THE OUTSET TO BE CLEAR
WE CONCUR WITH EVERYTHING THE
AUTHOR IT SAID.
THE CITY OF IRVINE IS NOT
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THE CITY
OF SUPPORT DATES BACK.
TO TWENTY FOURTEEN PERHAPS
TWENTY TWELVE WAS THE ORIGINAL
ACTION BUT THE PASSAGE OF AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE IT HAS
CONTINUED TO BE STE AND
STEADFAST SUPPORT OF GETTING A
VETERAN CEMETERY DEVELOP
CONSTRUCTED -- AND OPERATING IN.
THE CITY OF IRVINE.
WITH THE CITY'S POSITION AS A
SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS.
AND THE CITY'S REQUEST FOR THE
AMENDMENT IS THEY FEEL THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY JUST TAKING WHAT
THE ORDER NUMBERS WERE.
IN THE CITY'S ATTEMPT TO
JUXTAPOZ THOSE NUMBERS.
THEY THINK THE GOLF COURSE COULD
BE ABOUT A FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
A FIFTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR
ENDEAVOR.
WE'RE NOT WET TO THOSE NUMBERS
WE DON'T SUGGEST.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
BE BUT THERE'S NOT SEVENTY SEVEN
BUILDINGS TO TEAR DOWN THE THE
RUNWAYS ARE REMOVED FROM THE
PROPERTY LOT OF THE MEDICATION
HAS BEEN DONE.
AND WITH THE TWENTY FOUR AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS THAT THE
AUTHOR.
THE ORANGE COUNTY DELEGATION
YOURSELF MISS CHAIR THE SUPPORT
THAT'S BEEN.
HERE FROM THE STATE THAT SHOULD
BE COMMENDED COUPLED WITH WHAT
WE BELIEVE WILL BE TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT.
AND AND I KNOW MISTER CHAIR YOU
HAVE A LETTER TO THAT EFFECT --
WE THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE FUNDING TO BE IN PLACE.
AND WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT.
ALL INDICATIONS FROM STATE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS THE
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT THE TWENTY
FOUR AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
ON A NINETY ONE MILLION DOLLAR.
ARTIST SITE WE CAN'T GET MOVING
THE FEDERAL VA HAS INDICATED TO
THE CITY YOU HAVE TO THE TITLE
OVER TO THE STATE MOTOR START
THIS PROCESS.
SO WHAT WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING FOR
IS FOR THE LEGISLATION LIKE THEY
DID WITH ARDOR. TO SPECIFY ARE
TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO DO A
STUDY OF OUR NUMBERS ARE OFF.
THEN WE'LL KNOW WHAT OUR NUMBERS
ARE BUT IT'S ABOUT A FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR STUDY.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
AN AMENDMENT TO THAT EFFECT.
WITH THAT I HAVE P. CARMICHAEL
WITH ME FROM THE CITY OF IRVINE
HE'S BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS
PROJECT I'D LIKE.
TO TURN OVER TO KEEP OR ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION -- BEFORE
YOUR DIRECTION WANTED CLARIFY
YOU'RE NOT.
OPPOSED TO HAVING IT IRVINE I
MEAN THE THE CEMETERY IN IRVINE
YOUR YOUR WHAT DO YOU LOW WANT
TO LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
IT MIGHT COME TOGETHER THE CITY
HAS TO THIS IS A PROPERTY AND
THE CITY HAS CLEARLY STATED
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE VETERANS
CEMETERY.
WHETHER IT'S THE ARTIST SITE OR
THE GOLF COURSE SITE THEY WILL
DEEDED OVER ONCE THE FUNDING IS
IN PLACE AND THAT'S TO KEEP
PEACE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T DEAL
OVER.
THE PROPERTY.
IF IT'S NINETY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS AND WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR
AND A HALF.
THE THE OTHER PIECE ON THE GOLF
COURSE THE SHAPE THE GENTLEMAN
WAS ACT WITH THE SHAPE IS.
MISSILE DOES HAVE A CIRCULAR
SPHERE IN IN THE MIDDLE OF IT
BUT IT'S ALSO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT ACRES.
THE FEDERAL VA TELLS US WE NEED
A HUNDRED ACRES SO WE THINK YOU
KNOW WHAT THE STUDY.
IS A STUDY IT MAY BE A VIABLE
PROJECT THAT BLUE FORD.
SOONER THAN LATER AND NOT HAVE A
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS FUNDING
GAP.
SOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PLEASE A POINT OUT YOUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THE SHEER TIME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS PETE
CARMICHAEL.
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF OF
PLANNING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WITH CITY OF IRVINE
I'VE JUST A REAL BRIEF SET OF
PREPARED REMARKS WITH REGARD.
TO SOME OF THE THE THOROUGH DUE
DILIGENCE THAT CITY STAFF HAS
DONE IN THE CITY OF IRVINE.
AND SOME INFORMATION ABOUT THE
FACTS SURROUNDING THE VARIOUS
SITES IN THE CITY FIELD AND TOLD
TO MINUTE HERE.
ON JULY SIXTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MYSELF AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PROFESSIONAL
STAFF WITHIN THE CITY OF IRVINE
WHEREAS BY MEMBERS OF THE CITY
COUNCIL TO REVIEW WHAT HAS COME
TO BE KNOWN AS THE GOLF COURSE
SITE.
WITHIN THE FORMER EL TORO MARINE
BASE AND WITHIN THE ORANGE
COUNTY GREAT PARK AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE A. R. D. A
SITE.
OVER THE PAST YEAR WE THOROUGHLY
REVIEWED BOTH SITES THROUGH
PRIMARY PROFESSIONAL RESEARCH AS
WELL AS THROUGH EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE VA.
CAL THAT AND OTHER EXPERTS IN
THE FIELD.
WE BROUGHT THESE FACTS BEFORE
THE CITY'S TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING COMMISSION BOTH OF
WHICH RECOMMENDED THE GOLF
COURSE SITE OVER THE A. R. D. A
SITE AS THE SUPERIOR LOCATION
FOR A NEW CEMETERY.
I'M A BRIEFLY WALK THROUGH JUST
A COUPLE OF FACTS AS TO WHY WE
BELIEVE THE COMMISSION'S ARRIVED
AT THIS CONCLUSION SO QUICKLY.
FIRST AND FOREMOST -- WE LEAVE
THE ARE THEY ALREADY A SITE IS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPENSIVE.
BASED ON THE OWN REPORT
COMMISSIONED BY CAL THAT THE
COST FOR THE A. R. D. A SITE IS
NINETY ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
USING THAT SAME METHODOLOGY
STAFFS ESTIMATE FOR THE COST TO
CONSTRUCT THE GOLF COURSE SITE
IS FIFTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE REASON FOR THE COST
DIFFERENTIAL IS FAIRLY CLEAR.
THE GOLF COURSE SITE HAS BEEN
CLEARED OF ALL INFRASTRUCTURE.
ON TRADE WHAT YOU HEARD
PREVIOUSLY ALL CONCRETE RUNWAY
BUILDINGS TAXI WAYS -- WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY MEET REMEDIATION
OF THE SOIL IN PLACE.
THE A. ALREADY A SITE HAS OVER
SEVENTY FIVE BUILDING STILL
STANDING ON SITE.
EXTENSIVE UNDERGROUND UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE RUNWAY TAXI WAYS
AND THE ASSOCIATED.
KNOWN AND IMPORTANTLY UNKNOWN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS ON THAT
SITE -- WITHIN LAST WEEK FIVE
POINT COMMUNITIES HAS COMMITTED
TO CONTRIBUTING AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO
CEMETERY CONSTRUCTION ON THE
SITE.
IN ADDITION TO THE FACT THAT WE
BELIEVE IT'S THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS LESS EXPENSIVE TO START
WITH SO.
FIRST POINT BEING THE
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS WE
BELIEVE TO BE THERE FOR THE GOLF
COURSE SITE.
A SECOND HAS TO DO WITH TIMELY
AS WE BELIEVE THAT.
THE GOLF COURSE SITE AGAIN
BECAUSE IT MUCH OF THE
REMEDIATION IS ALREADY BEING
COMPLETE CAN BE CONCLUDED MORE
QUICKLY.
DEMOLITION REMEDIATION HAS BEEN
CALLED COMPLETED FOR THE GOLF
COURSE SITE I THIS IS YET TO BE
UNDERTAKEN FOR THE A. R. D. A
SITE.
I IN SPITE OF THE FACT THAT
CONCEPT PLAN HAS INDEED BEEN
PREPARED FOR THE A. R. D. A SITE
WE ESTIMATE THE GOLF COURSE SAY
CAN BE COMPLETED.
APPROXIMATELY SIX MONTHS SOONER
GIVEN ALL HE DEMOLITION
REMEDIATION IT'S ALREADY TAKEN
PLACE.
I WITH THAT JUST A COUPLE OF
OTHER CONCERNS I WANNA I WANNA
RAISE -- FIRST BEING -- IT'S
BEEN SUGGESTED THAT SOME OF THE
BUILDING STILL STANDING ON THE
A. R. D. A. SITE MAYBE HISTORIC.
ACCORDING TO THE VA ALL HISTORIC
STUDIES WOULD NEED TO BE
COMPLETED BEFORE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL REIMBURSE THE
STATE.
A FURTHER AND AGAIN ACCORDING TO
WHAT WE HEARD JUST THIS WEEK
FROM THE VA.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL NOT
REIMBURSE THE STATE UNTIL THE
ENTIRE SITE IS REMEDIATED
MEETING A PHASED APPROACH THAT
WOULD LEAVE THOSE BUILDINGS IN
PLACE -- WOULD LIKELY NOT BE
FEASIBLE.
SECOND POINT -- A. R. D. A SITE
IS BISECTED BY PRIMARY ROADWAY --
ALTHOUGH NOT A DISQUALIFIER
ACCORDING TO THE VA THEY DO
SPECIFICALLY LISTA PREFERENCE
FOR UNIFORMS SITES.
UNDIVIDED BY ROADWAYS ARE
EASEMENTS.
GOLF COURSE SITE HAS NO SUCH
ENCUMBRANCES.
OUR UNDERSTANDING THE FEDERAL
GRANT PROCESS IS THAT IT IS VERY
CAN.
AND AGAIN WHILE A SITE BEING
DIVIDED BY ROADWAYS NOT
NECESSARILY DISQUALIFIER -- WE
BELIEVE THE DIVIDED NATURE OF
THE A OR D. A SITE WOULD BE
INFERIOR TO THE CONTIGUOUS
UNIFORM SHAPE OF THE GOLF COURSE
SITE.
AND ONE LAST POINT -- THE RT
SITE HAS BEEN SUBJECT TO
OPPOSITION THE COMMUNITY.
THE A SIDE ACROSS THE STREET
FROM A CASE RIGHT SCHOOL.
YOUR MIND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SUBMITTED A LETTER JUST
LAST WEEK -- EXPRESSING THEIR
CONCERNS OVER THE SITE.
ASKING THE CEREMONIES INVOLVING
THE TWENTY ONE GUN SALUTE OR
OTHER DISRUPTIONS NOT BE ALLOWED
DURING SCHOOL HOURS.
THE GOLF COURSE SITE HAS HAD NO
SUCH OPPOSITION AND DOES NOT
HAVE THE SENSITIVITY SINCE HE'S
THE SCHOOLS ARE RESIDENTS.
IN SUMMARY I WE ESTIMATE THAT
THE ATA SITE IS SOME THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS MORE EXPENSIVE
TO BUILD.
THIS COUPLED WITH THE OFFER OF
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
RENDERS THE SITE NEARLY SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN THE GOLF COURSE I FURTHER
THE AIR DECIDE AS POTENTIAL
STORE CALLED DESIGNATION.
DIVIDED PSYCH COMPLICATIONS
MAKING IT LESS COMPETITIVE FOR
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT.
WELL THE GOLF COURSE SITE FALLS
SQUARELY WITHIN FEDERAL
GUIDELINES AND LASTLY THE GOLF
COURSE.
EIGHT DOES NOT HAVE THE
COMMUNITY IN SCHOOL DISTRICT
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED IN WRITING FOR THE A
OR D. A SITE.
IN CLOSING CHAIRMAN ARCHULETA
HONORABLE SENATORS BASED ON
THESE FACTS OUTLINED ABOVE WHEN
THE CITY OF IRVINE AND CITY
COUNCIL CONSIDERS THIS ISSUE
WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH.
CITY STAFF WILL BE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE CITY OFFER THE GOLF
COURSE EIGHT TO THE STATE AS
DISAPPEAR CHOICE FOR THE
VETERANS CEMETERY.
THANK YOU HAPPY TAKING QUESTIONS.
THE RECORD THE NUMBER OF THE
COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE CITY
MANAGERS AND SO ON THAT ARE --
CLOSER OR OR FOR THE SITE YOU
HAD MENTIONED THE GULF WAR TYPE.
THANK YOU KNOW HARD TO SAY THAT
AS I MENTIONED THIS IS COMING
BEFORE THE COUNCIL WITHIN THE
NEXT MONTH WHILE THE CLEAR
PICTURE I KNOW CERTAINLY -- OUR
MAYOR IS VERY MUCH FOR THE SITE
AND I BELIEVE OTHER COUNCIL
MEMBERS ARE -- BUT IN ALL
HONESTY BEFORE THERE'S A VOTE
WITHIN THE NEXT MONTH I DON'T
THINK I CAN.
THE ACCOUNT AT THIS POINT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT THE INDIVIDUAL TO OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS BILL KHó KHN THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
VETERANS MEMORIAL PARK
FOUNDATION.
MY CONNECTION WITH MCA SL TORAH
GOES BACK TO NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN WHEN I WAS A TWENTY YEAR
OLD MARINE SERGEANT [inaudible]
BROUGHT A BUSLOADS OF FRESHLY
TRAINED TEENAGERS UP FROM CAMP
PENDLETON LOAD THEM ONE AIRCRAFT
AND WE FLEW OFF TO VIETNAM
TOGETHER.
FROM THAT SITE THAT WAS THE LAST
PLACE MANY THOSE YOUNG BOYS STAR
LIVE ON AMERICAN SOIL.
I HAVE A PASSION FOR THIS PLACE.
WHEN I RETURNED FROM VIETNAM I
SERVE MY LAST DAYS IN THE MARINE
CORPS THERE?
PULLED OUT THAT MAIN GATE
[inaudible]
WE DO.
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA HAS
DONE FORCE.
WE CAME TOGETHER AS A COALITION
OF PEOPLE FROM NORTH COUNTY ARE
LITTLE LACK LOS AMIGOS MANY
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
THE AMERICAN LEGION [inaudible]
AND PUT VETERANS CEMETERY BACK
IN THE VOCABULARY OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA WHO
WE HAVE.
THE IMMENSE GRATITUDE FOR AND
WITH.
BROUGHT FORWARD AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE AND GOT US
A VETERANS CEMETERY ESTABLISHED
IT IN IN THE ESTABLISH THE WOULD
BE A VETERANS CEMETERY IN ORANGE
COUNTY [inaudible]
WE APPRECIATE -- CONTINUED
LOYALTY TO WORK BECAUSE MY BRING
FORWARD AB.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT I WOULD URGE
YOU TO MOVE AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT
FORWARD.
I WOULD PLEAD WITH YOU TO MOVE
IT FORWARD OUR GOAL IS THE
ORANGE COUNTY VETERANS MEMORIAL
PARK FOUNDATION IS A VETERANS
CEMETERY.
ON OLD MCAS EL TORO.
THE BEST WE CAN GET.
AND THE SOONEST WE CAN GET IT.
I HEARD YOU TO MOVE FORWARD BUT
WITH AN AMENDMENT.
I WOULD URGE YOU TO DELETE THE
REFERENCE TO THE ORDER IN THE
GREAT PART THE ART IS NOT.
IN FACT IN THE GREAT PARK AT ALL.
GIVEN MY DRUTHERS WHEN WE WERE
SEARCHING FOR SITES WAY BACK
WHEN.
AT THE AREA OF THE GOLF COURSE
BEEN AVAILABLE.
IT WAS NOT.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN WHERE I
WANT TO PUT MY FINGER WHERE
WOULD YOU WANT TO THE VETERANS
CEMETERY DAHLE [inaudible]
RIGHT THERE.
RIGHT THE MIDDLE OF A GREAT PARK.
RIGHT INSIDE THE MAIN GATE RIGHT
PAST ME INSIDE RIGHT ON THE
RUNWAY RIGHT SMACK IN THE MIDDLE
OF A GREAT PARK ON MCAS EL TORO
BUT WASN'T AVAILABLE.
OVER THE COURSE OF TIME
[inaudible]
WE'VE HAD.
ALTERNATE SITES PRESENTED.
AND DEFEATED YOU HAVE THAT IN
YOUR INFORMATION PACKETS.
WE NOW HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE FUNDING
THAT WOULD COME FORWARD.
WITH.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT WITH THE
GENEROUS COMMUNITY CONTRIBUTION
OF TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FROM FIVE POINT. TWO IS ALREADY
SPENT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN AMENITIES IN THE
GREAT PARK.
WE CAN BUILD CEMETERY WE CAN DO
IT NOW -- THE NEIGHBORS DON'T
LIKE THE ORDER I BEEN THERE YOU
CAN STAND ON THE ART OF LOOKING
THE BEDROOM WINDOWS.
THEY HAVE CULTURAL CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT WE TRY TO ADDRESS
WHEN WE MOVED TO STRAWBERRY
FIELDS.
THE SCHOOLS DON'T LIKE THE ARDA
YOU IMAGINE.
VETERANS CEMETERY WITH NO RIFLE
SALUTES.
I'M NOT HAPPY WITH THAT -- CVM
P. IS REALLY NOT FAVORABLE. TO
THE OUR SITE.
HAS BEEN STATED THERE IS A ROAD
THAT RUNS RIGHT THROUGH IT.
THIS ROAD WILL WILL RUN THROUGH
VETERANS CEMETERY.
FROM RESIDENCES TO HIGH SCHOOL.
I WOULD NOT WANT TO BE INTERRED
NEXT TO THAT WROTE [inaudible]
AT ALL.
IT ALSO HAS WHAT WAS OMITTED
FROM THE STONE WAS REPORT.
A PERMANENT FAA ARRAY A VERY
TALL ANTENNAS THAT STANDS NEXT
TO THE OLD TOWER.
EVEN IF YOU TO MOSTLY OLD TOWER
THAT IN TERNARY WOULD STAND.
WE FEEL THAT THE OUR SITE IS
OVERLY EXPENSIVE.
AND NOT COMPLETELY ADEQUATE. FOR
OUR DESIRES AS A VETERAN SENATOR.
IN LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS.
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE THIS AND IN
YOUR IN YOUR PACKAGE.
YOU WOULD SEE ALMOST A COMPLETE
SAVINGS ARE ABOUT SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT YOU WOULD NOT HAVE
TO SPEND ON A VETERANS CEMETERY
OVER THE COURSE OF TIME.
WE WOULD PREFER THAT YOU TAKE
THAT SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE NEEDS OF A
LIVING VETERANS.
SO I WOULD URGE YOU TO MOVE
THREE SIXTY EIGHT FORWARD BUT
AMENDED TO DELETE THE REFERENCE
TO THE ORDER AND REPLACE IT WITH
THE GOLF COURSE RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SURE.
NEXT THE INDIVIDUAL.
WHO IS IN OPPOSITION?
THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE.
BOB LOCHNER HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE IRVINE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THE POINT WE MADE IN THE
LETTER WE SENT LAST WEEK --
FIRST OF ALL WE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR
BEING SO AMENABLE TO OUR
CONCERNS WHICH ARE VERY VERY
BRIEF AND I THINK EASILY
ADDRESSED.
AS YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE LESS THAN A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS OF SCHOOL EVERY YEAR.
THAT'S LESS THAN HALF OF DAYS OF
THE YEAR -- AND DURING THE
REGULAR SCHOOL HOURS WERE
SOMEWHAT CONCERNED THAT THE
DISCHARGE OF FIREARMS.
WILL BE UPSETTING TO THE SCHOOL
DAY AND AND ALSO THE POSSIBILITY
OF DESENSITIZING THE COMMUNITY
SHOULD THERE ACTUALLY BE.
ALIVE SHOOTER WE HAVE ACT.
GRILLS IT'S AN UNFORTUNATE
REALITY SOAK UP THE THAT THE
AUTHOR STAFF OF BEEN WONDERFUL
WE DON'T THINK THERE'S
NECESSARILY A PROBLEM IN
ADDRESSING THIS WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE A MORATORIUM.
ON GUN FIRE DURING THE REGULAR
SCHOOL DAY -- THAT LEASE
WEEKENDS HOLIDAYS SUMMERS ALL
SORTS OF TIMES.
I UNDERSTAND THAT NOT EVERY OF A
FUNERAL AS GUNFIRE IT HAS TO BE
REQUESTED AND I WOULD IMAGINE IT
WOULD BE PRETTY EASY TO SAY IF
YOU WANT THAT THESE OF THE HOURS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
IF YOU HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS --
THE LETTERS IN FRONT OF YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD.
ARE THERE ANY ONE NOW -- IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
IT'S NOT AN OPEN UP FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AND I BELIEVE -- UP -- SAN
RAFAEL [inaudible]
OR THOMAS.
OR DO YOU USE IN YOUR IF YOU
LIKE.
WELL I DON'T DOES MATTER I CAN
HAS MY QUESTIONS AND THEN.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE AN INTEREST IN
THIS SO YOU CAN CLOSE IT OUT.
JUST TO CLEAR UP ONE ISSUE OF TO
THE TO THE ENGINEER SIR DO YOU
KNOW THAT YOU SPOKE ABOUT THE V.
O. R. ON THE SIDE YOU KNOW
WHETHER THAT FEEL OURS.
IN SCHEDULED FOR DECOMMISSIONING
BY THE FAA I TRIED DESPERATELY
TO GET THEM TO DO THAT BECAUSE
IT'S OUR TECHNOLOGY AS YOU ALL
KNOW.
YES.
PLEASE PICK UP SORRY I GPS IS
OBVIATED.
THERE'S A LIST YES AND IT O THE
LIST ON IT LAST I CHECKED YEARS
AGO IT WAS WAY DOWN THE LIST.
SO DONALD IT'S ON A DE
COMMISSIONING LAST SUNDAY YES
OKAY WHICH WE DON'T KNOW WHEN.
NOT FOR A LONG TIME WELL I DON'T
KNOW NEXT GEN.
GETTING A PILOT DIRECTION MOVES
ALONG SO.
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE STUDIED CORRECT.
YES IT WOULD BE WORTH LOOKING
INTO.
SO LET ME ASK ANOTHER QUESTION
DOES THIS I GUESS OF THE AUTHOR
DOES THIS BILL TAKE ANY
AUTHORITY.
AWAY FROM THE CITY OF IRVINE TO
MAKE THE LAND USE TERMINATION
THIS CASE AND THAT IS.
TO THE SITE THE CEMETERY.
AT THE ARTIST SITE OR DECIDED AT
THE GOLF COURSE SIDE OR FRANKLY
DECIDED SOMEWHERE ELSE WITHIN
THE CITY LIMITS -- AS WAS NOTED --
THE COUNCIL WILL BE BRINGING IT
UP FOR A VOTE THEY MAY AGREE
WITH THE ART A OR THEY MAY.
DISAGREE OR HAVE ALTERNATIVE --
MOTIONS.
SO IT DOESN'T TAKE AWAY IF THEY
CHOOSE SAY JUST SAY WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE ARTIST SITE AND
THEY BRING IT UP TO THEIR
COUNSEL.
BUT DO NOT WANT THE ARTIST SITE
THEY THEY LIST THE GOLF SITE
THEN OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD HAVE --
CONFLICTING.
WITH THE STATE NAME IN ONE THE
THE COUNCIL NAMING ANOTHER -- IT
DOES NOT MEAN THAT WE WOULD HAVE
A MANDATE OVER THEM OR YOU WANT
TO SAY A FRIENDS OVER THEM BUT
THERE WOULD BE.
A CONFLICT TO TO RESULT. TO THE
CITY COUNCIL RETAINS ITS.
WHEN USE OF THIRTY IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE TO DECIDE WHERE?
TO PUT THE CEMETERY OR NOT PUT
IT AT ALL CORRECT RIGHT.
BUT SO SO LET ME JUST BACK UP
WITH EXAMPLE FROM LAST TIME SO
WHEN WE ORIGINALLY SAID THE ARDA
THAT THERE'S WAS AGREEMENT AT
THAT TIME.
THEN LATER ON THEN THE
STRAWBERRY FILLED WAS DECIDED
BECAUSE WE MOVE FORWARD WE
DIDN'T HAVE A CONFLICT BETWEEN
SITE AND BETWEEN COUNSEL AND
STATE.
BUT HAD WE HAD A CONFLICT LIKE
POSSIBLY NOW.
THE NEXT STEP WOULD BE TRYING TO
RESOLVE THAT BECAUSE LIKE I SAID
IN THE BEGINNING.
MY INTENT IS NOT TO OF TO MOVE
FORWARD UP AT ANY POINT ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT WE MOVED
FORWARD.
REGARDING NAMING A SITE THIS
TIME WE FELT LIKE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING AT THIS NOW FOR SIX
YEARS.
AND WE HAVE TO HAVE A RESOLUTION
THERE'S GOT TO BE A POINT WHERE.
WE EITHER MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
HAPPENS OR IT DOESN'T AND SO THE
RESULT COULD VERY WELL BE THAT
THE COUNCIL DOESN'T AGREE WITH
THIS -- THIS SITE AND THEN AND
THEN AT THAT POINT WE HAVE A
CONFLICT AND WE MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO MOVE COMPLETELY FORWARD BUT
THE STATE DOESNT OVERRIDE THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THIS ISSUE SINCE. TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN OR FOURTEEN
HIS INITIAL MONEY CAME THROUGH
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NEVER FOR
WHICH I CHAIRED.
I THINK I VOTED ON THAT I VOTED
ON THE ONE BEFORE YOU HAVE YOU
HAVE VOTED ON Q. ANY MILLION SO.
I'M CERTAINLY INVEST.
IN THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
VETERANS CEMETERY SOMEWHERE --
IN ORANGE COUNTY.
I'M JUST WONDERING SINCE WE'RE
NOT TAKING AWAY THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ABILITY TO MAKE A
LAND USE DECISION.
BUT INSTEAD ARE AUTHORIZING --
CALVET DECIDED CEMETERY AT SOME
PLACE IN ORANGE COUNTY.
WHY DON'T WE DESIGNATE THOSE
SITES THE GOLF COURSE SITE?
AND THIS ARTIST SIDE AND LEFT
THE CITY COUNCIL.
MAKE DECISIONS THAT THE CITY
COUNCIL IS SUPPOSED TO MAKE.
BECAUSE LAST TIME I CHECKED
WE'RE NOT A CITY COUNCIL.
AND I THINK RIGHT EXACTLY AND I
AND I CAN HEAR YOUR DISCUSSION
ON THAT ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
ALL OF A SUDDEN.
WE'RE SERIOUSLY TALKING ABOUT
THE GULF SITE EVEN TWO WEEKS AGO
WE WERE NOT WAS THIS ALL OF THIS
NEW INFORMATION THAT NOW THERE
IS A A RENEWED PREFERENCE IF IT.
THAT NAMES THE GOLF SITE OR EVEN
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION JUST CAME
UP IN THE LAST IF YOU WANT TO
CALL IT WEEK OR TWENTY FOURTH
OUR IS ANOTHER WAY TO SAY IT.
WE PUT THIS LANGUAGE FORWARD
ALMOST THREE MONTHS AGO THERE
WAS MANY MANY TIMES THAT ON NOT
ONLY THE CITY BUT THE DEVELOPER
THEMSELVES AND THE VETERANS
GROUP COULD HAVE CALLED MY
OFFICE AND SAID LET'S SIT DOWN.
AND DISCUSS IT NOT ONCE HAVE WE
HAD THOSE REQUESTS SO IT IS
REALLY THERE IS A TRUST ISSUE
HERE WHEN WE'VE BEEN MOVING
FORWARD.
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN NOW I
MEAN EVEN LAST WEEK THERE WERE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WELL WOULD
WOULD WE JUST LOOK AT POSSIBLY A
HUNDRED ACRES BECAUSE THAT'S ALL
WE HAVE TO HAVE WE DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
ACRES.
OF THE ARTIST SITE -- WOULD WE
JUST CONSIDER THAT AND I'VE SAID
IN THE VERY BEGINNING AND I'M
HAPPY TO ALWAYS CONVERSE HAPPY
TO SIT DOWN AND WORK THINGS OUT
AND I WOULD BE.
AGAIN EVEN AFTER VOTE HAPPY TO
DO THAT WHAT IT TAKES.
TO OR THREE OR FOUR TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND SO WHEN YOU GET
SOME OF THIS INFORMATION COMING
AT THE LAST MINUTE LIKE THIS
MAKES IT HARD TO TO REALLY.
FEEL THAT THIS IS A SINCERE.
BUT I THOUGHT THERE WAS A MOTION.
SOME MOTION LANGUAGE THAT WAS
FLOATING AROUND AND YOU KNOW HOW
I FEEL ABOUT DOING MOTIONS AND
COMMITTEE BUT THERE WAS A MOTION
LANGUAGE FLOATING AROUND TO
AUTHORIZE THE CALVET THE SITE
THE CEMETERY.
AT THE OPTION OF THE CITY OF
IRVINE.
AND I DO THE GOLF COURSE SITE
WHERE THE ARTIST SITE AND WHAT
WHAT IT WAS THAT WITH THAT
MOTION LANGUAGE BE ACCEPTABLE TO
YOU ASSUMING THAT I HAVE NOT
BEEN PRESENTED AS THE AUTHOR
WITH THIS BILL WITH ANY OF THAT.
I'VE I'VE SEEN A LETTER THAT THE
CITY SAID I THINK TO THE SENATOR
NEVER SENT TO ME.
THAT SO I THINK THAT THAT'S
HIGHLY IRREGULAR I ALSO THINK
WITH HIGHLY IRREGULAR.
IS THAT A CITY ALONG WITH THE
DEVELOPER WOULD SET SENT A SIGN
A JOINT LETTER TOGETHER -- I WAS
ON COUNCIL FULLERTON CITY
COUNCIL.
FOR EIGHT BEFORE WHERE YOU HAVE
A CITY AND A DEVELOPER IN
ESSENCE Là BILLY OFF LOBBYING
JOINTLY TOGETHER ON CITY LETTER
HEAD.
VERY IRREGULAR SO THESE MAKE ME
WANT TO CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
AS THE BILL IS PRESENTED AND
THEN PUT THE TIME ON THE TABLE
TO REALLY LOOK AND SIT DOWN AND
MEET I WOULD LIKE TO SIT DOWN
AND MEET WITH FIVE POINT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SIT DOWN AND
MEET WITH THE CITY AND EVEN SOME
OF THERE ARE SOME -- COUNCIL
MEMBERS I MEAN I HAVE MANY MANY
TIMES DONE THAT BEFORE AND WE
COME TO A VERY SINCERE SOLUTION
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE TO THEIR TWO
OPTIONS OF COURSE ONE THIS
COMMITTEE.
I BELIEVE HAS ONE MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET BEFORE WE GO
HONOR INTERIM STUDY SESSION
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO IT
COULD BE A TO YOUR BILL.
BUT LET ME MOVE ON AND LET ME
GET TO THE THE REAL ISSUE -- IN
THE DIFFICULT POSITION I THINK
THAT THIS BILL PUTS US AND THE
SPREADSHEETS THAT I'VE SEEN ON
THE TWO SIDES AND I REALIZE --
ONE ESTIMATE OF CONSTRUCTION
FROM CALVET.
MAYBE QUETION BUT IT'S A CALVET
ESTIMATE.
AND THEN THERE'S AN ESTIMATE
CITY PUT TOGETHER FOR THE GOLF
COURSE ALTERNATIVE.
AND THE CALVET ARDA TOTALS
NINETY ONE MILLION DOLLARS EVER
TAKE.
AND THE GOLF COURSE ALTERNATIVE
IF THE CALCULATIONS ARE CORRECT
AND WHO KNOWS BECAUSE PERHAPS IT
SHOULD BE THE SUBJECT OF THE
STUDY WE'RE WE ACTUALLY
DETERMINE.
THE COST OF THESE TWO
ALTERNATIVES AND SELECT.
THE LEAST EXPENSIVE SATISFACTORY
SOLUTION RIGHT NOW THIS BILL
PUTS US IN BUT SOME OF US IN THE
POSITION WHO SERVE CONSISTENTLY
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR
SEVEN YEARS.
IN THE POSITION OF VOTING FOR
THE MOST EXPENSIVE. TWO
ALTERNATIVES.
IF IT'S TRUE IT NINETY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AS OPPOSED TO
STUDYING IT AND TRYING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER IN FACT. TO
FIFTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
SOLUTION.
IS EQUALLY SATISFACTORY CLOSE TO
THE STATE AND TO THE CITY OF
IRVINE SO YOU SEE THE POSITION
THAT THIS PUTS US AND SOME OF
HIS USER -- BUT WHAT I WOULD ADD
INTO THAT IS CAL THAT HAS NOT
STUDIED THE SECOND SITE AND THE
CITY HAS GIVEN INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THEY THINK THE COST IS.
AND WE ALSO HAVE TALK TO TELL
THAT ABOUT RE LOOKING AT THE
ARTIST SITE AND THEIR NUMBERS
REGARDING THAT THE COST THAT WAS
GIVEN.
NUMBER ONE IS IF THE SITE IS
USED FOR SAY RETAIL OR HOUSING
THAT.
COULD BE ONE DETERMINATION OF
SITE CLEANUP IF THE SITE IS USED
FOR BURIAL ARE THOSE SAME
NUMBERS USE SO WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO DETERMINE COULD
THERE BE AN ADJUSTMENT THERE IF
YOU'RE USING LAND FOR ONE YEAR
USE VERSUS THE OTHER.
AND COULD THAT REDUCE THE PRICE
THE OTHER THE OTHER ISSUE WAS A
LOT OF THE DEMOLITION COSTS AND
SO FORTH ARE TALKING ABOUT
REMOVING CONCRETE AND POSSIBLY
FINDING SOME TYPE OF CONNECT
CONTAMINATION ANOTHER.
UP.
TYPE OF SOLUTION COULD BE NOT TO
REMOVE IT AND BRING IN -- DIRT.
PUT OVER THE SITE.
SO THESE ARE SOME WAYS TO LOOK
AT COST SAVINGS THEY'RE NOT A
100% VETTED THEY'RE JUST
SOLUTIONS TO LOOK AT LOWERING
THE COST ONE OTHER OPTION WOULD
BE.
TO SLIGHTLY MODIFY THE BILL TO
SPECIFY AUTHORIZE CALVET SINCE
CALVIN IT'S NOT GONNA BE THE
DECIDER THE CITY OF IRVINE IS.
I'M TO GO TO ONE SIDE OR THE
OTHER AND THEN HAVING THE THE
STATE FUND.
THE STUDY NECESSARY TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE ACTUAL COSTS ARE.
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH THE
CALVET STUDY THE FIRST. ONE TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE ACTUAL COSTS
ARE WITH BOTH SIDES WITH THE
PROS AND THE CONS ARE SO -- NOT
THAT WE MAKE A DECISION -- BUT
THE CITY OF IRVINE WITH MAY BE
ABLE TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION AS TO WHICH SITE IS
BEST.
AND YOU'D HAVE YOU KNOW UNTIL
TWO WEEKS FROM NOW TO FIGURE
THAT OUT GET YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU THANK THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IF IF I COULD JUST REVIEW THE
HISTORY AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
THE ARTIST SITE WAS THE
DESIGNATED SITES SUPPORTED BY
THE COUNCIL SUPPORTED BY NUMBER
THE FOLKS THAT ARE HERE.
ARE SOME YEARS AGO IS THAT RIGHT
YES AND THEN AFTER THAT THEN
THERE WITHIN FIVE POINTS.
ATTEMPTED TO LOCATE THE CEMETERY
TO DIFFERENT LOCATIONS SO IT
DIDN'T INTERFERE WITH ANY OF ITS
DEVELOPMENT IS THAT RIGHT YES
AND THAT WAS DEFEATED BY VOTERS
IS THAT RIGHT YES.
AND THEN THERE WAS A COUPLE
OTHER SITES PROPOSE ONE IN
ANAHEIM.
RIGHT NO WHERE NEAR ANY
[inaudible]
HISTORIC -- ESTABLISHMENT REALLY
THE MILITARY YES IS THAT RIGHT.
AND THEN NOW NOW THE SITE.
IN UNFORTUNATELY IT'S BEEN IN
THE GOLF COURSE SITE IS NOT WHO
DO OF THE GOLF COURSE OTHER THAN
SOMEBODY THOUGHT MAYBE A GOLF
COURSE SHOULD BE THERE'S SOME
THAT.
RIGHT YES OKAY.
SO AND IN TERMS OF THE COST I
HAVE.
S. THAN WHAT I HAVE IN MY HAND
HERE IS I I THINK I HAVE THE
IRVINE STUDY AND MAYBE I CAN ASK
THE OPPONENTS OF THIS IS
ACTUALLY THE IRVINE STUDY THAT.
MISTER CARMICHAEL MIGHT BE ABLE.
TO I CAN HAVE YOU COME FOR
DINNER SURE.
IS THIS IS THIS IS SAYS THE
REQUEST OF PLANNING COMMISSION
ACTION IS THE ONLY THING I HAVE
IN TERMS OF THE STUDIES SIZE
THAT RIGHT THAT'S A SUMMARY THAT
WENT TO THE PLANNING COMMISSION
FEBRUARY THAT'S CORRECT ALL
RIGHT.
SO IN THIS IS WHAT I HAVE IN
TERMS OF THE ARTIST SITE.
IS THAT MR CARMICHAEL'S THIS
RIGHT.
IS THIS THE OUR SITE STUDY I
BELIEVE JUST BY LOOKING AT
THAT'S THE OWN REPORT
COMMISSIONED BY CAL THAT LOOKS
LOOKS TO BE OKAY.
AND IN TERMS OF THE TOXICOLOGY
OR THE TOXIC STUDY THAT WAS DONE
ON THE GOLF COURSE I WHO DID
THAT.
IS THAT IT'S SO FAR BEEN DONE BY
FIVE POINT IS PART OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE GREAT PARK SO
FIVE POINT DID THE STUDY THAT.
YOU BASE YOUR COST ESTIMATE ON
IS THAT RIGHT NO I COST ESTIMATE
IS BASED ON THE INS REPORT.
ACTIVELY IT WAS AN ADMITTEDLY A
VERY ROUGH ESTIMATE THAT
BASICALLY JUST BACKED OUT THE
PURSE WERE FOOT DEMOLITION OR
MEDIATION COSTS ASSOCIATE WITH
OUR TO OFFER THAT NINETY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
KNOWING IT DIDN'T NEED TO BE
DONE FOR THE GOLF COURSE THAT'S
THE ASSUMPTION IT DIDN'T NEED TO
BE DONE FOR THE GOLF COURSE THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT AND
THERE'S BEEN NO OTHER THAN THE
FIVE POINT ANALYSIS HAS BEEN
OTHER NO OTHER ANALYSIS AS TO
THE DEGRADATION.
OF THE SITE KNOWS THE GOLF
COURSE LIKE THAT RIGHT WELL
THAT'S A IT'S BEEN THE DIRT HAS
BEEN MOVED SO WE ACTUALLY OF
PHYSICAL EVIDENCE AS TO WHAT'S
THERE BECAUSE IT'S ALL IT'S BEEN
TURNED.
IN SYMPHONY ANALYZE THAT DIRT
[inaudible]
YES -- THAT DIRT WAS ANALYZED
AND WE HAVE A PROTOCOL FOR
REMOVING TOXIC SUBSTANCES DURING
CONSTRUCTION.
THERE WERE SEVERAL PIPES --
INSULATED PIPES REMOVED SEVERAL
OTHER REMNANTS REMOVED DURING
THE PROCESS SO WHO DID THAT
STUDY.
ARE THERE WAS A CONSULTANT THAT
WAS HIRED TO DO THAT DURING THE
PROCESS I DON'T KNOW OFF THE TOP
OF MY HEAD WE GET THAT PLEASE I
CAN PROVIDE THAT.
TO CERTAINLY SO IN TERMS OF THE
COST -- YOU HEARD MR FOR SCHOOL
ESTIMATE THE COST TO BE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS -- WITH WITH
CERTAIN MODIFICATIONS DO YOU
DISAGREE WITH ANYTHING HE SAID.
THE ONLY BECAUSE I KNOW THE A.
R. D. A SITE IS THE NINETY ONE
MILLION FROM THE CAL THAT.
ACTUALLY WAS SEVENTY MILLION
CORRECT IT WAS IN LATER AMENDED
BY CAL THAT TO NINETY ONE
BECAUSE OF COSTS PRESS OF
INFLATION WHAT WOULD THE COST BE
IF WE DIDN'T TAKE UP THE RUNWAY.
WELL I'D BE MORE SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE'RE ESTIMATING FOR THE GOLF
COURSE I TO BELIEVE IN THE RANGE
OF SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS SO WE
DIDN'T REMOVE THE RUNWAY.
THE SITES WOULD BE.
EVEN COURTING YEAR ESTIMATE
BASICALLY EQUALS THAT RIGHT.
HARD TO SAY I MEAN THEN YOU'VE
GOT A COST OF IMPORTING DIRT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE COST OF THAT
IS BUT YES CERTAINLY SEEMS TO BE
LESS EXPENSIVE.
AND AND I ALSO READ -- THAT THE
GOLF COURSE SITE.
DEVELOPMENT READY IS THAT
CORRECT -- YEAH I MEAN DEPENDING
ON WHAT YOU MEAN BY DEVELOPMENT
READY ALL THE INFRASTRUCTURE
RUNWAYS HAVE BEEN REMOVED AND
HAS BEEN TURNED.
I SEE IN THE IN THE DOCUMENT
THAT I SHOWED YOU AWHILE AGO THE
REQUEST THAT THIS IS THE IRVINE
STUDY
I SEE IT SAYS THAT THE THAT A
CONCEPT PLAN WOULD BE.
NEEDED TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
GOLF COURSE SITE IS THAT RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT.
SAYS IN YOUR IN THE IRVINE
DOCUMENT IT SAYS THAT THAT WOULD
TAKE -- TWELVE MONTHS THAT RITE
AID SOUNDS RIGHT AND LEFT ON MY
HEAD BUT YEAH IF IT'S THERE
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE ESTIMATED
OKAY.
IN TERMS OF THE COST.
IN TERMS THE COST SAVINGS
ASSUMING THAT MR FOR SCHOOL IS
CORRECT.
RIGHT IN WE LEAVE THE RUN WHEN
PLACE.
WE ESTIMATE THAT TO BE ABOUT THE
SAME CORRECT WELL KEEP IN MIND
THERE STILL SEVENTY SEVEN
BUILDINGS ON THE SITE THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE TORN DOWN IN ADDITION
TO THE RUN ROUTE SEVENTY SEVEN
BUILDINGS I'M NOT GETTING A
CHANCE TO CORRECT THIS.
OKAY BUT YOU'LL GET A CHANCE.
THE FIRST BILL -- ALL RIGHT
[inaudible]
THE ARM.
AND I HEARD TESTIMONY WITH
RESPECT -- TO WELL IF YOU IF YOU
AND I SHOULD AS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVE EVER
BEEN TO MILITARY FUNERAL EVER
BEEN TO A MILITARY FUNERAL.
YES SIR I YEAH.
YOUR FATHER SAID AND THEN THERE
WAS A RIFLE VOLLEY IS THAT RIGHT.
DOES NOT ARISE IF YOU IF YOU
HEARD A RIFLE VOLLEY FROM THE
FUNERAL.
ALL RIGHT SO IF YOU HAVE HEARD A
RIFLE VOLLEY FROM THE FUNERAL AS
SOME OF THAT'S NO DOUBT HAVE.
YOU YOU UNDERSTAND THAT'S
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN ANY
SORT OF SHOTS FIRED IN ANGER IS
THAT RIGHT.
PROBABLY ISN'T TO NOT SEEN IT I
WON'T ASK YOU THAT QUESTION
RIGHT BUT THE CONCERN ABOUT THE
DESENSITIZATION -- LEAK WAS FROM
THE OF THE ADMINISTRATION AT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH DOES HAVE
MORE INFORMATION AND DOES WORK
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THEIR
ACTIVE SHOOTER GIRLS.
SO.
I CAN GET MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT IF YOU'D LIKE I WOULD
BECAUSE AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
IS QUITE DIFFERENT THAN RIFLE
VOLLEYS AND IN FACT.
I HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT THAT MIGHT
BE A TEACHING MOMENT MIGHT BE
TEACHING MOMENT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO UNDERSTAND WHEN THEY HEAR.
THE RIFLE VOLLEYS BACK THAT
TEACHING MOMENT CAME FROM
TEACHER SHARON QUIRK SILVA.
THAT THOSE RIFLE VALLEY'S MAY
REMIND THE SCHOOL CHILDREN THAT
A VETERAN SOMEONE WHO SACRIFICE
AT LEASTPART OF THEIR LIFE IS
BEING BURIED BUT THE RIGHT.
AND WE REFERENCE THAT IN THE
FIRST PARAGRAPH OF OUR LETTER
THAT WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS AS A AS AN APPROPRIATE.
AND LONG STANDING WAY TO HONOR
THE VETERANS THAT SERVED US IN
THE RIFLE VOLLEYS WOULD SERVE AS
A TEACHING POINT PERHAPS ON A
REGULAR BASIS ILLUSTRATE.
PERHAPS ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
I'M.
IN MISTER FOSCO I I KNOW YOU
WANTED TO CORRECT SOME OF THE
INFORMATION SO I'LL TURN YOU
WHAT INFORMATION WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CORRECT.
FROM WHAT I JUST HEARD. THREE
THINGS THAT I'D RATHER I WANT TO
SOUND LIKE EVERYBODY NINE AS I
SAID JOE FRIDAY.
JUST THE FACTS.
THERE ARE NOT SEVENTY SEVEN
BUILDINGS ON OUR SITE HELLO BUT
I'M SORRY.
YEAH THERE ARE NOT SEVENTY SEVEN
BUILDINGS ON THE OR TO SITE
THERE ARE.
TWENTY FIVE I HAD. THREE
CERTIFIED MEMBERS OF THE
NATIONAL DEMOLITION ASSOCIATION
CONTRACTORS GO TO THE SITE WALK
AT ALL AND GIVE ME WRITTEN BIDS
ON REMOVING EVERYTHING.
I HAVE IT.
THE LOCK STOCK AND BARREL OF ITS
SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL THEY REMOVE
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED SQUARE FEET
A DAY IT'S A HUNDRED DATES.
IT'S ALL CLEAR.
AND THE GRADE THE SITE.
AND FOR AN EXTRA MILLION THE ALL
ALL THE UNDERGROUND.
SO THAT'S ABOUT SIX MILLION.
ALL IN SITES CLEAR LOOKS THE
SAME AS THE GULF SIDE NOW.
AND THEN FOR FOUR MILLION YOU
BRING UP YOUR INFRASTRUCTURE IN
MASQUERADE THE PROPERTY SO NOW
IT'S ALL SMOOTH NICE DIRT.
ELECTRIC GAS POWER DRAINAGE
WATER EVERYTHING'S RIGHT AND NOW
YOU BUILD YOUR SUMMIT THERE. TEN
BUCKS A SQUARE FOOT IS A
DYNAMITE CEMETERY.
SO YOU CAN DO THE MATH QUICKLY.
THIRTY MILLION FORTY MILLION FOR
THE WHOLE.
HUNDRED EIGHT SOME FIFTY MILLION.
BUILD YOU THE ENTIRE PLACE.
IN TWO YEARS.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT
YOU CAN DO PHASE ONE SO THAT WAS
ONE THING I HAVE TWO MORE THINGS.
ON SO THAT WAS ON THE COST IT'S
SIX MILLION THE OWNER REPORT
SAYS IT'S TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
SO THAT'S A BIG.
BUMP.
IT'S NOT SEVENTY SUDDENLY IT'S
UNDER
THE SECOND THING IS THAT --
MISTER CARMICHAEL USE THE WORD
UNIFORM WHEN HE DESCRIBED THE
GOLF COURSE AND I CAN'T THINK OF
A MORE.
MISS ONLY BEHOLD WORD IT IS NOT
UNIFORM THIS SITE IS HORRIBLY.
DISFIGURED IF YOU WELL ANYBODY
THAT DEVELOPS AND BUYS LAND
WOULD WALK ON THIS SITE BECAUSE
OF ITS SHAPE.
SO I DON'T CARE IF IT'S CHEAPER
PERSONALLY WHY WOULD YOU.
TAKE AN INFERIOR SHAPE SITE AND
START POURING MONEY INTO IT THE
YIELD ON THAT SITE WILL BE POOR.
SO IT'S A GOOD THING IT -- IS
BECAUSE YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO GET.
TWO THIRDS OF THE GRAVE SITE YOU
WITH A GUN ON THE HARD OF SIGHT.
I'M SORRY THAT'S JUST A FAST.
FINALLY IS NOT TWENTY ONE GUNS
AT SEVEN AND IT'S ONLY FOR GUYS
AND BULLETS FLYING OUT
[inaudible]
I UNDERSTAND.
WELL IT.
IS IT NO DOUBT.
AND I THINK THERE'S PLENTY OF
VETERANS.
THAT I JUST READ MY DAD AT ALL
YEAH BUT I HAD THAT EXPERIENCE.
NO MY KNOWN AS A PLEASE.
YOUR COMMENTS.
YOUR EXISTING.
BUT I'M NOT A MILITARY.
IN BACK TO MY QUESTION OR TEASE
THE DEMOLITION IS NOT.
A FORMIDABLE OF EXPENSIVE ITEM
AND THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
LET ME AS THE AUTHOR QUESTION.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PRO.
OF PROHIBITED PRECLUDE.
THE FUTURE STUDY OF ALTERNATE
SITES IS THAT RIGHT.
RIGHT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THAT CONCLUDES MY QUESTIONS.
IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL FOLLOW UP.
I HAVE YET TO HAVE AN ANSWER TO
MY BASIC QUESTION WHICH IS WHY
ARE WE DOING IT.
IF THE CITY COUNCIL RETAINS THE
AUTHORITY TO MAKE ITS DECISION
AS TO WHERE TO CITE CEMETERY.
OR NOT THIS IS THE CITY COUNCIL
CAN CHOOSE A SITE BUT IN ORDER
TO HAVE A VETERANS CEMETERY THEY
HAVE TO PARTNER WITH THE STATE
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I
UNDERSTAND THAT SO IF THEY
CHOOSE A SITE DIFFERENT FROM
THIS BILL.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE BACK HERE
NEXT YEAR WITH ANOTHER BILL IF
YOU AGREE WITH THEIR SITE
SELECTION.
WELL WHAT WE HAVE SAID IS AFTER
THIS MOVES FORWARD AS IT IS WERE
WILLING.
TO AS IT MOVES TO APPROPRIATIONS
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION I MEAN
THERE THERE COULD BE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS THAT COULD.
CHANGE THE FACTS AS FAR AS OF
MORE INFORMATION WE'VE JUST
HEARD RIGHT NOW ALL THAT.
WINDOWS THE SENATE ANALYSIS CAME
OUT IT SAID THAT THE GULF SITE
WAS READY TO GO AND THAT.
WHAT THE HELL THAT HAS NOT EVEN?
ANALYZED IT THE SECOND PART IS
THAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE TIMING WHICH WOULD BE FASTER
OR I MEAN ON EACH SIDE YOU CAN
SEE THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
TIME.
OR AMOUNT OF TIME THAT IT'S
GONNA TAKE TO MOVE BOTH OF THESE
FORWARD DEPENDING ON IF YOU.
JUST ANALYSIS TO START WITH THE
GOAL SITE WOULD REQUIRE THE BILL
TO BE SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
WHICH COULD BE.
YOU KNOW.
AS EARLY AS THE MIDDLE OF
SEPTEMBER OR IT.
YOU KNOW THERE'S ALL OF THAT TO
WILL THAT WHICH WILL HOW WILL
THE GOVERNOR WAY AND WHAT DOES
HE HAVE A PREFERENCE ALL OF
THESE THINGS NOTHING CAN START
INTO YOU.
SECURE THE REMAINING.
WHATEVER IT IS LET'S SEE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS RIGHT
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO THERE'S STILL TIME ATTACHED.
AND YOU CAN SEE THERE'S PROS AND
CONS ON BOTH SITE BUT RIGHT NOW
WE WANT TO DO IS MOVE FORWARD
WHAT WE HAVE BECAUSE THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAD UP INTO
THE LAST FEW DAYS.
WAS THERE WAS NO INTEREST IN THE
GULF SITE THE GULF SO IT JUST
KIND OF APPEARED AM I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS WHY DOES THE CITY
HAVE.
THE SITE OF THE GULF SITE
CLEARED ALREADY.
AND IF THAT WAS OF MAJOR SITE TO
pTHIS LANGUAGE THREE MONTHS AGO
WHY DIDN'T THEY CONTACT US AS AN
AUTHOR AND SAY HEY THIS IS
CLEARED IT'S READY TO GO.
CAN YOU SIT DOWN AND WORK WITH
THIS WHY DID WAIT THEY WAIT TILL
THE LAST LIKE FOUR DAYS THE TEST
THAT QUESTION REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE CITY OF IRVINE -- WITH
THE IMMINENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN CHASING GUNS ALL
THIS WE HAD A ROUND OF MEETINGS
WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
DELEGATION.
IN JANUARY OR FEBRUARY WE LAID
OUT THE CITY'S THE SIT WHEN I
SAY WE THE CITY MANAGER HAS
EXECUTIVE STAFF WE MET WITH THE
AUTHORS.
I'M OFFICE UNFORTUNATELY THE
AUTHOR WAS UNABLE TO ATTEND THE
MEETING BUT IN FAIRNESS TO THE
CITY THEY LAID OUT THREE
POSSIBLE OPTIONS.
AND THEY WERE GOING TO TAKE IT
TO THE MAYOR AND THE COUNCIL TO
THE CITY COUNCIL.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS THE BILL WAS
AMENDED TO SPECIFY ARDA AND
THOSE THREE OPTIONS BECAME
RATHER MUTE -- SO.
AND IN THE THREE OPTIONS TO
CLARIFY WHAT'S THE GOLF COURSE
THAT WAS SHARED WITH THE ENTIRE
DELEGATION.
AS WELL AS THE ARTIST SITE AND
POSSIBLY EVEN WHICH HAD EVEN
BEEN PROPOSED POSSIBLY EVEN A
HYBRID SITE.
SO.
YES THINGS HAVE RAMPED UP AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS STARTED TO
MOVE HER BILL AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THE CITY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATES.
THE AUTHORS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
WE JUST FEEL LIKE GOING BACK ARE
THOSE FIVE YEARS OLD WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE GENTLEMEN'S
ANALYSIS OF REMOVAL.
THOSE ARE NOT THE CITY'S NUMBERS
THE NINETY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH PERHAPS CALL BACK AWAY IN.
COULD BE A HUNDRED TEN WE DON'T
KNOW THAT THAT ANALYSIS THAT
REPORT WAS STROMBERG HAS IS
DATED.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING CAN WE PLEASE
GET THE DEPARTMENT TO LOOK AT
ALL SITES SO THAT WAS A LONGER
ANSWER THAN YOU WANTED MISTER
CHAIR AND?
WE DID HAVE DISCUSSIONS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR WHY DIDN'T
THE CITY IN TWENTY TWELVE BRING
UP THE GULF SITE ARE IN
201-420-1220 THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
STATE.
HERE'S WHERE WE'RE WE'RE HERE I
THINK EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM LOW
WELL PLEASE IT WASN'T ONE
MEETING THAT CAME TO ME AND WE
WERE JUST DISAGREEABLE WE
FINALLY PUT A LOCATION AND WE
AMENDED ARBOR BILL.
BECAUSE WE COULDN'T GET ANY
SPECIFIC RESPONSE FROM THE CITY
ABOUT WHAT THEY WANTED WE WOULD
JUST HEARING THINGS FROM THE
BATHROOMS AND THE AND PART OF ME
MR.
SENATOR BUT THIS SHOULD NOT BE
DRIVEN BY DIVERT DEVELOPERS AND
I AM GETTING OUTRAGE THAT WE'RE
SITTING HERE WAITING ON
DEVELOPERS WHEN THIS IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE.
AND OF THE COUNCIL THIS SHOULD
NOT BE WAITIN BY BECAUSE
SOMEBODY SAYS OKAY I'M GONNA
THROW IN TWENTY EIGHT MILLION.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT'S CAN EVEN
COME WE'RE SAYING WE HAVE A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR?
SHORTFALL WE DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE ANY SHORTFALL BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY FORMAL LETTER
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO DO THIS
HOW DO WE KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO
DO THIS.
IF I MAY IN YOUR MAKE MY
COMMENTS ANY OTHER.
DAMAGE FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
THE V. IN YOUR OPENING STATEMENT
YOU HAD MENTIONED THAT.
YOU'RE OPEN TO COMPROMISE YOUR
OPEN TO LISTEN -- AND WE ALSO
HEARD THAT THE CITY OF IRVINE IN
THE CITY COUNCIL IN THE COUNTY
OF ORANGE -- THIS IS A LOCAL
ISSUE TO THEM AND THEY SHOULD
HAVE A SAY AND I UNDERSTAND THAT --
THEY CAN OVERRIDE ANYONE BECAUSE
IT IS THEIR CITY.
THERE COUNTY AND THEIR DECISION
ON THAT SIDE.
THE OTHER THING THAT YOU HAD
MENTIONED THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO
WORK TOGETHER.
CHAU IF THE VERBIAGE SAID THAT --
ARTIST SITE OR THE GOLF COURSE
SITE.
OF THAT WOULD THROW THINGS OFF
FOR YOU IF IF IT CAME OUT THAT
WAY.
I'M NOT WHAT I'M SAYING WE'RE
DEALING WITH WHAT WE HAVE
FORWARD RIGHT NOW THAT.
HASN'T EVEN IF THE WORD.
FOR WOULD THROW THIS OFF I THINK
YEAH WE ALL WANT.
TO THE CEMETERY EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN THIS ROOM AND EVERY
VETERAN SURE OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY AND AND THOSE WHO ARE NO
LONGER WITH US -- AND THOSE WHO
WISH TO ONE DAY BE BURIED.
AT THE CEMETERY IN.
ORANGE COUNTY AND I THINK WE ALL
WANT IT QUESTION IS WHICH WOULD
BE THE SITE.
AND AND TO PURSUE THE QUESTION
OF WHICH ONE I I GAVE MY WORD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND AND AS I
SAID I DO SUPPORT THE BILL
HOWEVER.
DUE TO THE COMPLEXITY IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS ISSUE.
AND THE INFORMATION THAT HAS
RISEN OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS
JUST RECENTLY.
IT WAS IT IS MY FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THIS BILL RECEIVE A FAIR AND
HONEST HEARING.
AND I THINK WE'VE DONE THAT.
AND I'VE ALLOWED EVERYONE TO
SPEAK.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A DEEPLY
EMOTIONAL ISSUE THAT FOR SO MANY.
BECAUSE THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR
THE DIGNITY AND RESPECT OF OUR
VETERANS.
AND THEY DESERVE THAT.
AT THE END OF ALL THIS POLITICAL
MANEUVERING AND YOU HAD
MENTIONED.
OTHER INDIVIDUALS IT IS THE
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT
SUFFER FROM.
IN ACTION SO WE ARE LOOKING FOR
AN ACTION AND I'M HOPING THAT
WOULD BE ONE THAT WE CAN
COMPROMISE ON WE OWE IT TO THEM
TO FIND AT THE RESPONSIBLE
SOLUTION.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BUILDING PRINT TODAY BECAUSE
IT'S MY COMMITMENT. TO BOTH OF
YOU.
AND TO THE AUTHOR.
HOWEVER I WOULD HAVE PREFERRED
THE BILL INCLUDE.
WORD FOR THE LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
OPEN THE DOOR -- TO FURTHER
DISCUSSION.
AND I THINK IT'S NOT TOO LATE TO
DO THAT.
THAT BEING SAID I WANT TO LEAVE
IT UP TO MY FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- TO MAKE YOUR
DECISIONS -- BASED ON THE
KNOWLEDGE AND RESEARCH OF ALL
MAY.
BUT REMEMBER THIS.
THE VETERANS.
ARE TO BE.
ACKNOWLEDGED AND THIS IS THEIR
WISH AND WHAT WAS THE BEST
COURSE WE CAN TAKE. TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN SO -- WITH THAT THERE ARE
NO WITH OTHER.
I'M SORRY I KNOW.
SO WITH THAT I'M GOING TO LET
THE AUTHOR.
CLOSE WITH REMARKS.
DOES THAT WE WOULD RESPECTIVELY --
ASKS FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
LEGISLATION AS IT'S WRITTEN.
I HAVE A MOTION THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
OF YEAH.
NOT TODAY.
THAT IS YOUR RECOMMENDED IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A RECOMMENDATION
BEFORE WE TAKE THE VOTE
[inaudible]
THERE'S A OKAY LET ME JUST LET
CENTER.
TO I DON'T HAVE A COMMITTED
AFTER CHECKING [inaudible]
OKAY.
MOST OF THE FRAUD MOVE THE BILL.
WITH A VOTE.
AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT TO PASS
FIRST REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS.
ARCHULETA I OR SOMEONE I GROWTH
[inaudible]
AUTO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
ROTH.
NUMBER I NUMBER I WILL
[inaudible]
I THREE ZERO THE MEASURE SO I
MOVED CALL.
WE WILL DO THAT.
WE HAVE RECESS JUST MOMENTS
.
WE'RE GOING TO GO.
YEAH WE'RE GONNA HOLD OVER ON
CALL.
AND THEN -- CORRECT CORRECT AND
THEN [inaudible]
MR.
SO I WOULD I IN I KNOW I WAS IN
A MEETING AND I DO APOLOGIZE FOR
NOT COMING IS A FEMALE THAT
TREND THE ONLY ONE ACTUALLY IN
THIS.
IN THE SENATE I VETERANS IT
ISSUES ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO ME.
AND WE HAVE A NATIONAL CEMETERY
IN KERN COUNTY.
I KNOW THAT IT'S VITALLY
IMPORTANT HAVE A VETERANS
CEMETERY IN LOCATIONS WHERE
PEOPLE CAN GO VISIT THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS IN THE RAIN I GET IT I
KNOW THAT YOU'VE WORKED ON THIS
BILL FOR A REALLY LONG TIME.
I GUESS MY POSITION IS AND AND
WE WE TALKED ABOUT IT.
IF YOU WOULD JUST ACCEPT THE MAN
WITH THE WORD OR IN IT AND THAT
GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR EITHER
SITE TO BE DEVELOPED EITHER THE
AIR.
STRIP SITE IN THE GULF SIDE --
IN THEN IT BE A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONAL ISSUE IS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT NOT TRUE
IF THEY CAN PICK.
THEN WITH THIS WE CAN SAY OKAY
YOU GET EITHER ONE OF THE SITES
YOU PICK DOWN IN YOUR AREA WHERE
YOU GUYS LIVE.
IN IN -- YOU KNOW ON THE OTHER
SIDE BEING SENT REPUBLICAN
LEADER AT CENTER MORLOCKS
DISTRICT TO HIS MIND MEMBER.
AND HE SUPPORTS BOTH A THAT IN
ITS HIS DISTRICT AS WELL.
SO I WOULD ASK IF YOU TAKE AN
AMENDMENT WITH THE WAR IN IT SO
WE CAN PASS THIS OUT YOU CAN
NEGOTIATE WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO
IN APPROPRIATIONS.
AND HOPEFULLY THIS WILL GET THE
GOVERNOR SETS. THREE CAN SHE
ANSWER THAT SIR.
WELL OBVIOUSLY HAVING.
TO EXCHANGE LIKE THIS TODAY WITH
OTHER PARTIES HERE BEING PART OF
THE EXCHANGE IS NOT IDEAL AS I
STARTED MY COMMENTS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS HEARING IS.
UP.
IS THAT WE WANT TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS CEMETERY SO
I WILL JUST REPEAT THAT -- THERE
SOME HIGHLY IRREGULAR --
WEIGHING IN ON THOSE OF
EVERYTHING FROM A JOINT LETTER
WITH A DEVELOPER AND A CITY ON
LETTER HEAD THAT IS VERY UNUSUAL.
THAT OF THE TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
JUST KIND OF APPEARED WITHIN THE
LAST FOUR DAYS AND IF IT REALLY
IS TRUE THERE WERE MEETINGS THAT
I WASN'T PART OF THAT SURE
CERTAINLY IS OFFENSIVE AS AN
AUTHOR OF BILL.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT MY DOOR IS
ALWAYS OPEN AND SO WHETHER IT BE
THE CITY WHETHER IT BE THE
COUNCIL MEMBERS.
OR EVEN THE DEVELOPER COMING
STRAIGHT TO ME AND SAYING HEY
THIS IS IMPORTANT AFTER ALL OF
US AND THE VETERANS INCLUDED.
LET'S GET ON THE SAME PAGE THAT
CERTAINLY HASN'T HAPPENED SO IT
PUTS MY RAIDER RADAR UP.
I'M STILL NOT CONVINCED THAT TO
A BUT BECAUSE IT APPEARS THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
FACTORS HERE SO -- CAN I ASK THE
SENATE WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THIS
GOES OUT AND DOES NOT GET OUT
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW
WHAT ARE THE OPTIONS.
IT WILL HAPPEN IS WE'LL MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE OTHER -- THE
OTHER BILLS.
AND THEN AT THE END OF IT -- BUT
AGAIN IF IT FAILS THEN YOU CAN
REQUEST FOR RECONSIDERATION.
AND THEN THE VOTE ON THE
CONSIDERATION AND THEN WE HAVE
OUR LAST HEARING FOR THIS YEAR
IS ON THE LINE SO TO COME BACK.
IT WOULD HAVE A NOTE MOTIVATED
THAT.
IT'S A STRAIGHT [inaudible]
NO.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA THEN I'M JUST
GOING TO HOLD OUT FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I HOPEFULLY
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T
TALK TO ME DIRECTLY.
WILL -- ON CALL OKAY.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION OKAY.
IF IT'S FIFTY S. IF IF THIS DOES
NOT GET OUT TODAY I WOULD LIKE
THE CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA GO ON WITH THE NEXT
ORDER OF BUSINESS.
AND THAT IS -- WHICH WOULD HAVE.
WON NUMBER.
ONE AND ASSEMBLY MENTIONED
SOMEBODY BILL THREE AWAIT.
MARK GIGI ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AB THREE WHICH TAXATION.
YES AT A PROBLEM.
CENTERS I PROMISE A MUCH SIMPLER
AND MUCH LESS.
CONTROVERSIAL.
THANK YOU SIR.
ASSEMBLY ABOUT A BILL THREE ZERO
EIGHT IS A SIMPLE MODEST BUT
IMPORTANT BILL TO PROVIDE A TAX
BREAK FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
SOLELY OWNED BY DEPLOYED
SOLDIERS THIS BILL SEEKS TO
RESTORE A PREVIOUSLY EXISTING
TAX EXEMPTION FROM THE MINIMUM
FRANCHISE TAX FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
SOLELY OWNED BY DEPLOYED MEMBERS
OF THE UNITED STATES ARMED
FORCES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS -- HERE HE
OF MISTER CHAIR -- MEMBERS ALEX
TAURUS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES WHERE
CONSORTIUM OF SEVEN NONPROFIT --
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCY SERVING
VETERANS -- ACROSS STATE FROM
GREEK A SAN DIEGO SERVING ALMOST
TEN THOUSAND VETERANS -- WE JUST
WANTED TO ASK OUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL WE THINK -- GIVEN THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SMALL BUSINESS
BUREAU REPORT THAT SHOWED
CALIFORNIA HAD THE DISTINCTION
THE HONORABLE DISTINCTION OF
HAVING THE MOST AMOUNT THE
LARGEST AMOUNT OF VETERAN OWNED
FIRMS.
IN THE COUNTRY -- WE THINK THIS
IS ALSO GREAT -- GREAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AID SOME OF THE
TRANSITION FROM ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE.
TO CIVILIAN STATUS SO AGAIN I'D
LIKE TO THINK -- SOMEONE
MURATSUCHI FOR HIS TREMENDOUS
WORK ON THIS -- WE'RE JAVA THANK
YOU VERY GOOD IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IS ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THAT TO ME OPEN UP MY COLLEAGUES
[inaudible]
YOUR COMMENT [inaudible]
OKAY -- THE BILL.
THE MOTION.
AB THREE ZERO EIGHT TO PASS BUT
FIRST FOR PREPARATION ARCHULETA
HI ACTUALLY I GROW.
AUTO AYE.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE ROTH.
NUMBER [inaudible]
WILK.
IT DOES.
YEAH IT HAS OF COURSE SO IT'S
GOING TO PASS THANK YOU SIR --
WE'RE GONNA HOLD. FOR THE OTHER
BOATS THANK YOU THANK.
THE INTEREST OF TIME LET'S GO
AHEAD AND DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR YES SIR MOTION PLACE.
WE HAVE MUCH OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AB FIVE EIGHTY ONE AND EIGHTY
ONE TWELVE FIFTY SEVENTY PASSED
BUT FIRST REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT.
ARCHULETA HI ARTS LITTLE I GREW.
HOW DO I ROTH [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible] THREE ZERO AND
THERE'S NO I HAVE TO SET UP.
A LITTLE BOUNCE OUT THE
APPROPRIATION AND WILL HOLD AND
THAT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN.
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
OKAY
.
THANK YOU SIMILAR MEMBER THANKS
FOR BEING HERE AND YEAR -- AB.
FIVE FIFTY AND THE MEDICAL
FOSTER HOME PILOT PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB FIVE FIFTY WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH A MEDICAL FOSTER
ON PILOT PROGRAM.
LOCAL FOSTER HOMES ARE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ELIGIBLE
VETERANS TO LIVE AN INFORMAL
PRIVATE HOME ENVIRONMENT RATHER
THAN AN INSTITUTIONAL SETTING AB.
FIVE FIFTY IS THE PATH WITH
MAKING THAT POSSIBLE.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED SUPPORT
FROM MANY CARE AND VETERANS
GROUPS INCLUDING A A RP.
AND AM VETS WITH ME.
I DID HAVE SUPPORT I THINK YOU
MAY HAVE ALL.
BILL ALONE NOW.
WHITNEY IS ME HAPPEN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
OKAY ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT.
THIS BILL VERY CALM THEY'RE JUST
DORMANT.
GO THING.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- DON HARPER
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN LEGION.
I'M THE CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATION
COMMISSION WE HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND LEGION AIR'S IN
CALIFORNIA -- ONE THE LARGEST
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE.
OF TOTALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
MR CHILD STORES AGAIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REMEMBER SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GI FORUM.
AMVETS.
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL AND COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS.
ON SPORTS THANK YOU.
GOOD THANK YOU ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY WITH THAT THE MOTION.
WELL I THINK -- WE'VE HAD A
MOTIONS.
BUT I'M SORRY I'D MAKE THIS
QUICK THIS IS AN EXCELLENT IDEA
AND I NEVER EVEN HEARD ABOUT IT
BEFORE IF THE BILL GETS AMEND I
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
IF.
THAT HAPPENS LOVE.
TO LOVE TO YEAH GREAT I GREAT
IDEA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MOTION CENTER
HER TITLE.
HELLO THE VOTE.
AB FIVE FIFTY TWO PASSED THE
FIRST REFERRED PREPARATIONS
ARCHULETA.
ARCH Là I GREW.
TADO THE TOTAL AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I ROTH [inaudible]
NUMBER.
WILK BOOK I IT JUST.
HOPE THAT OPEN.
IT DOES PASSED CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERSION
FOURTEEN LOVE IN OUR VETERANS --
MAYOR CENTER NUMBER [inaudible]
OKAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM ON A. B..
SIX FIVE THREE AND STATE
ARMORIES.
THE THING OR STAY WITH HER
[inaudible]
YEAH.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
WHO AFTERNOON THAT -- I'M
PRESENTING AB SIX FIFTY THREE
WHICH AUTHORIZES THE DIRECTOR OF
TO ENTER INTO A LEASE AGREEMENT
WITH THE COUNTY OF LA.
FOR THE WEST LA NATIONAL GUARD
ARMORY SITE.
MY OFFICE AND THE COUNTY UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF SUPERVISORS
SHE LOOKED KILL HAS OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF BEEN WORKING WITH RELEVANT
CITY STATE AND FEDERAL PARTNERS
TO DISCUSS THE FEASIBILITY.
OF BUILDING BRIDGE HOUSING SIDE
OF PROPERTY.
THE WEST LOS ANGELES ARMORY IS
SITUATED WITHIN SERVICE PLANNING
AREA FIVE IN LA COUNTY.
WHICH COVERS MOST OF THE WEST
SIDE AND SPEND SOME OF THE
HIGHEST PROPERTY VALUES AND ALL
CALIFORNIA.
AND PROBABLY COMES AS NO
SURPRISE IT'S BEEN NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND SITES FOR AN
ARM HAS A FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS DUE TO
THE HIGH COST OF LAND.
IN ALREADY TENSE LARGELY BUILT
OUT REGION.
THIS PROJECT WOULD BE THE FIRST
BRIDGE HOUSING SITE FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS IN SPOT FIVE IN OVER
TWENTY YEARS.
THE SPECIFICS OF THE PROJECT ARE
BEING DEVELOPED WITH COUNTY
ARCHITECT AND THE NATIONAL GUARD
AND DESIGN SHOULD BE COMPLETED.
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS THEN OF
COURSE THERE WILL BE ROBUST
COMMUNITY OUTREACH -- IN OTHER
IN THE COMING MONTHS MARTHA
GUERRERO OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY'S.
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICE IS HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
pYOU HAVE THE NAME IS THE CHAIR A
MEMBERS MARTHA GUERRERO
REPRESENTED LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THE SPONSOR
MAYBE.
SIX FIVE THREE WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM INTRODUCING THE
BILL AND FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
AND AS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
HAS -- MENTIONED THAT THERE IS A
NEED FOR ESTABLISHING --
PERMANENT -- YOU KNOW SOME
PERMANENT SHELTER -- RICH
HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
NEED IN THIS PARTICULAR SPIRAEA
THERE REALLY FIFTEEN AND WOULD
LIKE TO EXPAND IT TO ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
AND AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THEM WE
HAVE A HOUSE THE SENATE
BUILDINGS -- AND LANGUAGE OF THE
DEFENSE BILL SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
A SIMULTANEOUSPROCESS TO GET
THE AUTHORIZATION I'M TO DO THIS
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
QUESTION COMMENT [inaudible]
IS YOUR FOR THE BILL I SUPPORT
EMPIRE COMMITTEE BETTER WHAT I
DIDN'T ASK IS -- WHAT WHAT WERE
IN WEST LA SAYS WELL I GOT THE
WILSHIRE?
RATHER OTHER STUFF IS WHERE
WHERE IS IT THIS IS -- VERY
CLOSE TO THE VA FACILITY IT WILL
SURE ARE AND TO IN IN WHAT WAS.
GREAT WILL TURN BETTER AND
THAT'S EXPENSIVE REAL ESTATE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AND MY QUESTION IS.
VETERANS WILL IT BE SERVING.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER FOR
IT IS IT'S VETERANS OR GENERAL
PUBLIC CORRECT IT'S A
COMBINATION COMBINATION HOW MANY
HUNDRED EVENTUALLY.
INDIVIDUALS MEN AND WOMEN.
THAT -- MOTION.
MOVE THE BILL.
AB SIX FIFTY THREE DO PASSED
FIRST REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
ARCHULETA HI.
I GREW.
BOTTOM RIGHT.
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
ROUGH [inaudible]
I NUMBER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
WILL.
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY -- WE'RE NOW IN A A. B..
SIX NINETY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
ONE BETTER AND HOUSING AND
HOMELESS PREVENTION BOND ACT.
TWENTY NINETEEN YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF AB IS SIX NINE FOUR AN AXE
THE VETERAN HOUSING AND HOMELESS
PREVENTION BOND ACTIVE TWENTY
NINETEEN TO AUTHORIZE THE
ISSUANCE OF BONDS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING.
WITH SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
VETERANS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS APPROVED PROP
TWELVE THE VETERANS BOND ACT OF
THE TO AWAIT FUNDED MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROVIDERS VETERANS
CREATING THE HHT OVER FOUR
ROUNDS OF FUNDING VS HP HAS
PROVIDED NEARLY.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED TOTAL
HOUSING UNITS FOR THE VETERANS
AND FAMILIES THERE IS NOW ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED NINETY MILLION
REMAINING FOR THE H. H. P. AT A
RATE OF SEVENTY FIVE MILLION PER
ROUND THAT FUNDING WILL RUN OUT
IN. TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO GET A
BOND ON THE TWENTY TWO THE BILL
WILL HAVE TO GET PAST THIS YEAR
OR WITH AN URGENCY NEXT YEAR.
THERE AN ESTIMATED TWELVE
THOUSAND HOMELESS VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN MORE
EXPERIENCING HOUSING AND
SECURITY OR STRUGGLING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET AND THE TRANSITION.
ACCORDING TO H. CD APPROXIMATELY
79% OF CALIFORNIA VETERANS WHO
RENT SPENDING MORE THAN 50% OF
THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING.
AB SIX NINE FOUR WILL ASSIST
VETERANS WHO ARE HOMELESS OR WHO
NEED AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING
SECURES A HOUSING FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR -- THANK YOU.
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AGAIN I DON HARPER WITH AMERICAN
LEGION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL WE NEED MORE HOUSING FOR
VETERANS IN THIS IS A GREAT.
DEAL ON A BOND THANK YOU.
GREAT [inaudible] TO OUR STORES
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TWENTY WITH
THE A CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION HERE'S PERSONAL
THANK YOU.
THAT RIGHT THERE IN READING
ASSOCIATES FOR PLAYING A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL.
WE'VE BEEN FORWARD [inaudible]
NONE [inaudible]
THAT.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OUR MOTION.
HAVE THE MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL.
EIGHTY SIX NINETY FOR THE PAST.
OPERATIONS ARCHULETA.
HI.
I GREW.
DONALD.
I NIELSEN.
AYE ROCK.
I AMBER WILK ALL RIGHT WILL THAT.
I WE HAVE.
AN EASY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR OR
SOMETHING
[inaudible]
WHEN YOU?
OPEN IT UP.
I'M GONNA START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AB FIVE EIGHTY ONE AND TWELVE
FIFTY SEVENTY PASSED THE FIRST
FOR FOR CORPORATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS CONSENT GROWTH
[inaudible]
ROTH.
HI ROTH I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I THAT PASSES SOUTH.
AB THREE ZERO EIGHT TWO PASSED
THE FIRST REFERRED PREPARATIONS
GROWTH.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER GUY REALLY PASSES OUT.
AB.
THREE SIX THE APPLICATION.
AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT TO PASS THE
FIRST RE REFER TO PREPARATIONS
[inaudible]
AND THE ROCK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT.
I AM GOING TO VOTE.
I TO MOVE THIS BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY TO THE FLOOR TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
I AM -- CLEARLY NOT HAPPY WITH
THE PRESENTATION AND THE
WILLINGNESS OF THE AUTHOR TO
ADDRESS WHAT I BELIEVE TO BE
SERIOUS ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO
THE BILL.
I AM FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF A
VETERANS CEMETERY IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
SINCE I'M A LOCAL CONTROL GUY
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN
INTERFERING WITH THE WRITER THE
ENTITLEMENT OF THE CITY OF
IRVINE TO DECIDE WHERE THAT
CEMETERY GOES -- IF AT ALL I
THINK THAT'S A LOCAL ISSUE TO BE
DECIDED BY LOCAL ELECTIVES.
WHO WERE RESPONSIBLE AND
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE CITIZENS OF
THAT PORTION OF ORANGE COUNTY --
BUT HAVING SAID THAT MY I THINK
MY CONCERNS HAVE BEEN ADEQUATELY
SPREAD ON THE RECORD TODAY AND I
WILL BE VOTING ON THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
IF I MAY HI BEEN HERE TOO IS A
LONG TIME MEMBER OF THE VETERANS
COMMITTEE AND FOR MANY MANY
YEARS THE SENATOR FROM THE ONLY
VETERANS HOME IN CALIFORNIA.
I'VE DEALT WITH THESE ISSUES A
LONG TIME.
IN A BID ON THIS COMMITTEE QUITE
A FEW YEARS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THE INTENSITY
AND FRUSTRATION.
IN THIS COMMITTEE EVER.
WE'VE SEEN HERE AS THIS
DEVELOPED.
THAT'S VERY UNUSUAL AND I DO
UNDERSTAND LOCAL.
FORCES AT PLAY.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT.
AND ALSO.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO PUT MY TRUST
IN THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE THESE DAYS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE REALLY
IS A LOST JURISDICTION.
THE DECISIONS ON THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR AND AMENDMENTS ARE MADE
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
BUT THAT SAID I'M PREPARED AS MY
COLLEAGUES GENDER ROTH TO VOTE
YES TODAY.
ON THIS BILL.
LET IT MOVE ALONG. TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND KIND OF HOPE THAT ALL
PARTIES CAN COME TOGETHER.
IN SOME KIND OF GOOD FAITH.
IT ALSO DISTURBS ME.
THAT AS I HAD TO LEAVE FOR A
VERY IMPORTANT MEETING IN MY
OFFICE BUT THE HE IT APPEARS
THAT THE AUTHOR WAS NOT EXTENDED.
PROPER COURTESIES.
IN TERMS OF SOMETHING THAT
NEEDED TO HAVE BEEN BROUGHT TO
HER ATTENTION.
THAT'S ANOTHER VIOLATION OF
PROCEDURES.
AND WHAT I CALL SENATORIAL
COURTESY AROUND HERE THAT YOU'RE
TAKES ME ALSO.
SO COLOR ME IRRITATED THAT COLOR
ME AS A YES VOTE AND I WILL STAY
ENGAGED AS THIS BILL MOVES.
THE VOTE THANK YOU AB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT TO PASS FOR THREE
REFER TO PREPARATIONS GROWTH.
NIELSEN.
I ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK [inaudible] TWENTY
THREE BASS ON AB FOR NINETY
EIGHT THE PAST GROWTH.
RICARDO [inaudible] SIX AB FIVE
FIFTEEN TO PASS THE FIRST
REFERRED PREPARATIONS GROWTH.
ROTH AYE AMBER.
AMBER GUIDES.
AB.
SIX FIFTY THREE DO YOU PASSED
THE FIRST REFER PREPARATIONS
GROWTH.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I AM BURKE